Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, I don't think I have any words.
I literally have never played Game of Life.
It's literally life!
Okay, basically, you can go to college or don't.
But you go to college, you get into debt.
And then you can have kids.
Oh, you're forced to have kids, by the way.
You're forced to get married and have kids.
Yeah, so...
So, like, basically, it's life.
Basically.
But we're all chronically online, so it's like...
You get to experience what it's like to have, like, an actual life outside of streaming.
That's basically it.
Wait, let me just...
I thought this was like Monopoly!
It's two different keys!
You can't buy a house though, can't you?
I'm pretty sure.
Well, you can.
You can technically have a house, but it's like one house.
Oh my god.
Okay, I have your, like, VOD Ninja bow.
Okay, the quality, like, re-stabilized.
It was like 220p or some shit earlier.
Yeah, it's really wonky at first.
Sometimes it'll, like, poop itself, but then it'll come back.
It's kind of like Discord audio.
Yeah, yeah, alright.
Where's the chroma key?
Alright, green.
Hello!
Oh my god, you're so loud!
I'm powerful!
Also, I'm live!
Yeah, yeah, we're all live.
We're all live?
We're all live except for Doobie.
You are so loud, Fillion.
I'm not loud!
Oh my god, I need to turn you down.
I put you at 70.
Yeah, yeah, I literally put you...
I had her at 200 from our last thing we did together.
So, what happened to my mic, huh?
You just want to act mean to me on stream.
Wait, wait, Fillion, where's your VOD Ninja thing?
Yeah, of course, of course.
We all did the assignment that you gave us.
My assignment is going to be...
We all did the assignment.
Give me a second, you're putting pressure on me.
Frick you.
Listen, my internet is just not good enough for it, you know?
What do you mean?
Your entire thing is about 3D.
Yeah, I'm giving it to you right now.
What?
Oh yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, I put the lobby code so you can join whenever.
Wait, you did everything?
What do you mean?
I was going to do this.
You're just taking my job.
Okay, I bought the deluxe.
I had the deluxe version, which was like $100, but I had it before.
So...
So, like, it basically...
I just like to revisit this conversation.
Well, the thing is...
Bow, the thing is, I'm not in debt, so I could afford it.
See, that's where all the thinking starts.
Yeah, like, I can...
I can afford it because I'm not in debt, Bow.
That's the thing.
Well, are you going to go for college route, Bow, then?
Are you going to go to college?
No, I'm just going to buy a bunch of houses.
You can only buy one house!
This is not Monopoly!
What do you mean a bunch?
You can only buy one!
She hasn't, no.
It's okay.
It's okay, Bow is going to know what actual real life is outside the internet today.
Yeah, we get to experience what it's like.
Yeah, that's the game of life.
I think the Mark Zuckerberg...
I'm pretty sure Metaverse died.
Yes, don't leak it.
Do not leak the code.
I do not leak the code.
Until the lobby is full.
There's a grey line at the top.
Where?
Oh, I see it.
I mean, I could just create a new lobby and you leak it, but I prefer not to.
Let's not leak, I don't see anybody.
Yeah, I just see you and...
I just see...
Doobie's the only one that joined the collab.
Wait, okay, okay, okay.
I dropped my code, okay?
I'm a little bit behind.
I did my job, okay?
You literally organized this collab, Elliot.
Too busy on Omegle.
Too busy on VTuber Omegle.
VTuber Omegle.
Yeah, yeah.
Doobie was watching the VTuber Omegle and was commenting.
What do you think, Doobie?
Pretty cool, huh?
Yeah, it's cool, but I'm worried where somebody's doing something weird behind, you know, the exact thing.
I don't know.
Here's Omegle.
Here's the thing, okay?
They can only use their VTube model.
Yeah, but you can literally Google a picture.
You can Google a picture.
But they...
Oh, you're right.
You can Google a picture.
Oh my god, you just walked in.
I'm just gonna make you look tiny on my head.
I'm just gonna put you on my head.
What do you mean, Doobie?
She's not even streaming.
I'm the one messing us up.
We're both blonde.
Is that why?
You can't see it.
The color yellow.
I can't see anything.
I'm the angel.
She's the devil.
Okay, I'll put you...
Okay, so...
I'm going to hop on to the game.
Alright?
Yeah, the code is out.
The code is out?
Yeah, it is.
It's literally in the chat.
Don't say the code out loud.
Well, to be fair, Bao's not even in it yet too.
I'm coming.
I know where to put Fillion.
She's like walking everywhere.
I will pick my position and then we'll be chilling, okay?
I promise.
Video Ninja?
Copy.
Okay, I'm bringing you on Bao right now.
Alright.
Yippee, I'm in.
Guys, at least we didn't start 30 minutes late.
That's like an improvement for VTubers.
We were on time!
Isn't that crazy?
We didn't start the game on time, but small steps, you know?
You guys are the biggest video window ninjas I've ever seen in my life.
Why is your background like an effing navy blue?
Because it's the default!
What happened to green?
I just...
It's literally default.
You can figure it out.
Just color drop it.
I think I'm behind Doki right now.
I can't tell where I am because you're effing...
Blue window is murder.
Where do I put her?
Oh my god, where do I put her, guys?
I don't even know.
I also don't know.
I just put her right next to you guys.
I think she's walking everywhere.
Bro, your jacket is half of this world.
I put my jump to zero.
What if we put...
Maybe I should just use a PNG.
I forced her to be 2D.
I have to be slightly green.
Come on, man.
Wait, don't leave me up here.
You know what the Fillion ninja reminds me of?
It's like those ads that pop up on Nickelodeon on the bottom right.
And they just come out.
That's what she reminds me of right now.
Next up on Nickelodeon.
Spongebob.
And she's just moving around.
Bro, you are literally invisible on my screen.
I don't know what to do with you.
I just put the similarity down.
Bro, I did!
I clicked pick screen color.
I clicked on you.
Oh, yeah, true.
Doobie would know.
She knows all the technology stuff.
I actually realized I did make a strategic error.
Yeah, huge.
What is it?
Did that fix it?
No, that made it worse.
You can make it 0.1?
Yeah.
That didn't work at all.
Wait, Bow, you were able to figure it out, right?
Yeah.
I'm gonna make you into a ghost jacket.
Bow was able to figure it out.
Ninja is your thing.
Okay, Bow, what's your secret sauce?
Okay.
You can pick screen color.
And then whatever the background...
Yeah.
It'll just make it disappear.
How many years have you been using Ninja?
Uh, well...
Here's the thing.
I can explain.
So, what happened was that...
When I was picking a custom color...
Yeah?
Well, I'm actually colorblind.
Oh, wait, really?
You're colorblind?
She's literally lying, bro.
No, it's like...
If you make fun of me, you're really bullying a disabled human.
How do you feel about that one?
He got fact-checked.
You can't say that!
Can we have a note from your doctor or something?
Yeah, of course.
Please share a doctor's note before making these claims.
My entire chat is my doctor.
They're like a part of my mind.
It's like chat is my therapist.
That's like not...
They are!
Come on, let's be honest, guys.
Chat is our therapist.
At least one of them should be a licensed therapist.
But, like, I don't know which one it is.
I mean, to be fair, I get lawyers...
It's like asking chat for legal advice.
Dude, I do ask them for legal advice!
Oh, no.
Dude, I said, should I give away 100 subs?
And they said yes, and now I'm broke.
No, no, Fillion.
I did it for my family.
This explains so much about your career.
Whatever.
What's in your chat?
Uh, no, no.
That's kind of freaked out, bro.
I'm like trying to make Doki fully transparent.
Wait, what?
Doki, Doki, Doki, listen to me, okay?
I know you're in a literature club, but I need you to stop becoming a ghost.
What?
You're a bachelor!
Do anything for the cause!
It's literally just you.
Is she freaked up too on your screen?
It was fine, and then it got freaked up.
Wait, how?
I don't know.
Okay, alright.
I'll disappear for a second.
You're just enabling her, Bal.
You know it.
No, I'm not.
She won't learn!
She won't learn if you stop, if you enable her.
I'm not enabling her.
She won't learn.
And you know it.
She just told me I could buy multiple houses.
Bal, check your PayPal.
Okay, have you guys ever bribed someone for content?
No!
What in the world?
Okay, well, we're going to be playing the game of life today.
We're not a reality show, we're real.
Girls, my DMs are open.
Okay?
If you want the W in this game, I am a professional at life.
Oh, gosh.
I've done life very good.
So you can just hit me up, and I'll make sure you're good.
Any believers?
Any believers in chat?
Even Doobie doesn't believe you, and this is her first collab with you.
I'm considering it.
You're considered Doobie?
No, don't listen to the devil.
Why are you calling me devil?
Don't listen to...
Well, she's not calling you an angel.
Yeah.
You're like the snake in Adam and Eve.
That is so mean!
Bro!
Snakes are cool, but they're cool.
You're talking a lot of smack.
We're being a walking piece of KFC.
KFC, you effing chicken looking thing.
Huh?
What's up?
Technically, we're all animals.
Except, I think Fillion's a fake cat girl.
She's not real.
Just a furry?
Yeah, she's just a furry.
I prefer the term cosplayer.
I'm a cosplayer.
Just every single day of your life.
Every day with a tail up your ass?
Yeah, that's cosplay.
Here's the thing.
Okay, Doki?
I'm gonna say this right now.
You're talking about my tail?
Let's talk about your neck.
What's wrong with my neck?
Your neck is longer than my patience right now.
Okay, it doesn't take that much though, to be fair.
If I needed tomorrow's weather forecast, I'd tell you to look behind your shoulder.
You are a walking Alolan executor.
Executor is pretty cool though.
He is.
It is pretty cool.
I feel like those are just compliments right now.
Thank you.
Bro, you wanna be a vegetative creature when you grow up?
Executor is the coolest Pokemon out there.
Like, look at him.
It's true.
Have you ever seen giraffe fights?
They're actually so hardcore.
They get their necks done.
They smack people with their necks.
That dude's actually kinda sick, I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah, okay, you know who's missing in my lobby?
There's one person missing.
Let's take a guess on who it is.
Who is it?
Who could it be?
I'm in the game!
You're not in the lobby!
Okay, give me one sec.
I can do this.
How do I...
Here?
Doki, I have a special request.
There's a code.
Scroll up.
Just scroll.
What the...
That one?
Yeah, like...
Wait, Doobie, Doobie!
Can you do a cool face too?
Uh...
I saw Bao's face.
I like that.
Bao, you do a funny face now!
No, she's been doing a funny face.
Wait, that's so cute.
Yeah.
I can do a funny face too.
Wait, don't...
Aren't you doing one all the time?
Yeah, aren't you...
No, no, no, no, no.
Wrong outfit, wrong outfit.
Furry!
Stop!
If you're not a furry, take off your ears right now.
She's literally in like a Chester the cheetah outfit right now.
Wait, really?
I'm not a furry!
Take off my ears?
Yeah, take off your ears right now.
How am I supposed to do that?
Oh, well, furry.
No, no, no, okay, fine, fine.
Take off your ears right...
Oh, you can't take it off.
No, I can do this.
The hardest wills require the strongest sacrifices.
Fuck you.
Oh my god.
She really does look like the Spongebob ad right now.
She's like the Nickelodeon next up on Spongebob Squarepants.
Oh, yeah, when the characters like walk on the screen.
Yeah, yeah, that's what...
I get it.
It looks like a halftime transition stinger for a TV show.
Yeah, you look like a stinger on a TV show.
Okay.
I just got a rate up on my face right now.
I just need a text to go over it.
Oh my god, live on stream.
Hear it.
You know, maybe we could just put a computer as our foreplayer.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, I'm joining the lobby, bro.
Relax, okay?
Relax, calm down.
Alright, let's see this junk.
Bink, bink, and then here.
Music on.
I turned on my music because I'm a chad.
How about you guys?
What, the music from the game?
Yeah.
Yeah, no, I've been listening to the same music for 10 plus minutes.
20 minutes, actually.
Yeah, I'm like losing it.
Yeah, no, this is like similar to Pico Park right now.
It's just one track.
It's literally one track of song.
Okay, if I enter the lobby code, we'll get leaked.
Yes.
Walk the code.
I don't know, your chat might be faster at typing this than you.
Type it in and then you can show it because it'll be a full lobby.
Wait, so I have permission to leak the code?
No, you have permission after you've typed it in and got in because then your chat might be faster.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now, everybody can leak the code, guys.
You can all leak the code.
The code is 7284.
If you don't grab my IP, I'm going to be severely disappointed.
If anybody shows up at my house, because I'm the lobby leader, fill in.
Oh, oh, no, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
And we're starting the game.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, start the game, start the game, start the game, start the game.
We're starting the game.
Alright, I chose the space map.
I thought it would be appropriate.
Yeah.
We're gonna go to Mars, everybody.
Whoa.
I'm a better seagull.
Look at me and my furries right here.
Wait, dude, you gotta do outfit color coordinate.
I'm an effing marsupial in space.
We're literally in space.
If anybody, you guys didn't coordinate with me.
Okay.
You can either go to college or career.
If you win, it's because you cheated.
You can't say that.
I'm not reading anything.
Wait, what is this?
You gotta choose your job, so there's space port operator.
You became a space operator?
Yeah, but you don't pay that much.
She joined the space force?
That's basically the space janitor.
I'm a blue collar worker.
Yeah.
What the frick?
What are we gonna do?
What is this?
Can someone explain the rules?
Slow down.
Slow down and explain.
What did happen so far?
You either get to get a job or go to college.
If you go to college, you go into debt.
More knowledge.
But you can have a chance to get a better job and earn more money.
But you have to pay off your college tuition afterwards.
I want a comic book.
Did you just pick up a comic book?
Yeah, so there's bonuses.
Types of bonuses you can get from the cards itself.
And stuff like that.
You can choose to buy one house.
Not houses, Bao.
One house.
And also...
Did you guys know that comic books are the clone of NFTs from the 90s?
What?
Yeah, you can sell them for higher.
Yeah, exactly.
They're like collectibles.
But like, NFTs are digital that you can now keep and own.
Okay, so it's legal.
That's what buying and selling is.
Okay, so hear me out.
We're gonna make a video game.
You and me and Doobie and Bao.
You guys are in, right?
We're going to put the blockchain in this junk, okay?
Wait.
This is why you don't say yes without hearing it out.
Now, listen, okay?
We are going to talk to Kazuna Ai and she's gonna be in.
Big business.
Big decisions.
What do you think?
Do you remember when I said Fillion is like the snake in Adam and Eve?
What does that mean?
No, no, no.
Okay, hold this.
No, hold this.
We'll make a really good video game and then we'll call it Elden Bling cause it's dressed to impress combined with I like that, yeah.
Thank you.
We can make VTuber Crypto Zoo where the eggs hatch Okay, yeah.
Calm down.
Okay, Bao, are you gonna go to college or?
I wanna be a starter Pokemon.
Where did that come from?
We're trying to decide college or career.
Hold on, hold on.
College, pay 100k to level up your education you get a better job.
Go to college.
Go to college, Bao.
I'm gonna go straight into my career.
Yeah!
You wanna be a caretaker or a moon miner?
That's a dream.
Nurse or...
Nurse or miner.
You can be Steve.
If you make moon miner into a sentence with moon as the verb it becomes very problematic.
You're so stupid.
Spin to move?
What does that mean?
What do you mean, what does that mean?
You played board games before!
Wait, she just ran out of money!
She ran out of Adobe!
She'll be okay.
She has insurance, right?
Get a rare comic book.
I don't think...
I mean, you get more bonuses if you upgrade your computer.
You can be a streamer if you upgrade your computer.
You can become a streamer!
Wait, but isn't she broke?
Yeah, I'm gonna be a streamer.
You paid $200,000 for a PC, Bao.
You just got scammed hard in the music video.
What if it has a 9080?
It could have a 9080!
Yeah!
What are you gonna compute with that?
I don't think Doobie needs that junk.
Bao's gonna go 3D.
No, she'll go 4D.
Has no one here gone to college yet?
No, it's not worth it.
In this economy?
You're saying, Fillian, you're the little snake in the garden.
You don't watch this.
Chat, go to college.
Get a job.
Become smart.
You know what I'm saying?
How does this work?
I just feel like we of all people cannot be credited.
Is this not working?
I'm literally spinning.
Let go.
Just spin harder.
This is why Fillian went to college, guys.
Bro, I've been spinning this.
Why doesn't this work?
This is why Fillian's going to college.
Bro, this is like when you open a bottle of pills and you can't figure it out.
How does this work?
I'm spinning it.
Just spin.
I'm gonna circle a bunch.
There!
You're spinning the wrong way.
Someone please help me.
Okay.
Someone grab the NPC.
Why was that so hard?
Oh, hey.
Hi.
I'm finished college.
You did it.
What the hell?
You spedrun it.
Oh my god.
Four years.
You did it.
Guys, guys, silence.
I'm becoming... Wait, what is this?
You have the most knowledge.
Thank you.
Every day I read a book.
Hold the crown till the game wins.
Okay.
Here goes my job, guys.
Look out.
Here it is.
Your girl Fillian is gonna grow up and become a rocket engineer.
Oh my god.
I'm like a whole explorer.
Oh, but you have to pay more taxes.
Oh, no.
You should take it.
You should do a rocket engineer.
Should I explore holes or rockets?
No, you should.
Let me know in the comments section.
Alright.
Rocket?
Dude, the hole sounds crazier.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay.
On the other hand...
Fillian, look at the taxes you pay.
Yeah, you subtract one right now.
Guys, I'm going to start drama.
I'm gonna start drama.
Doobie3D 3-dimensional commits tax evasion.
If she can do it, I can.
It just picked for me.
Good job.
I guess I'm a rocket engineer.
Fillian, spin the wheel.
You can spin again.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I don't know, bro.
How am I ending a combo on a frame one?
You did it.
Nice.
Action is coming.
Camp one of the stars or mow the neighbor's lawn.
I did not study to become a rocket engineer to mow lawns.
I'm thinking about the economy right now.
You get money.
You get 80k.
What do you mean?
I'm on the pursuit of happiness.
Oh my god.
Dude, the stars called me.
I can't believe you skipped out on 80k.
Bro, okay, then how about you go to college, idiot?
No, it's fine.
I played this game before, so I know how to win.
You know the meta.
I know the meta.
I'll be a travel agent.
What are these taxes on the moon, dude?
What are they, space travel agents?
I lose like 90% of my income.
Oh shit, who was nine?
Oh, Doobie got 50k.
God damn it.
I got robbed by a janitor.
What?
You just made a million bucks, Doobie.
That's fine.
Watch a game stream?
Check that out.
How crazy is that?
Gain some knowledge.
I'm gonna mow the neighbor's lawn.
Yeah, exactly.
I've already lost 50k to Doobie.
This is what you could've had.
This is what you could've had, 80k.
You literally set a bad example for the audience.
No, in this economy right now...
Oh my god.
Not gonna lie, but...
Right now, if you're an American right now, and you have college tuition, it's pretty fucking bad.
Get a raise or get a new job.
Oh, take the gamble.
You don't wanna be a janitor forever.
Let's go gambling.
I'm not a janitor.
Okay, you're a spaceport operator.
That's practically a space janitor.
Discord mod.
Oh true, you're a space mod.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh frick, she's re-rolling?
No, I don't like these.
Wait, what was your last...
How much did you make in your last job?
What do you mean?
I'm literally a space travel agent.
What do you not like about that?
It's literally my job.
We're co-workers.
We'll defend a move.
I still don't understand how Fillion struggled spinning this.
Bro, I'm in virtual reality.
No, we're not.
We're virtual YouTubers.
Stay single, stay on your path, or get married.
Start your family to get love.
You don't need a family.
Yeah, exactly.
Wait, so how do you win this game?
You win this game by having the most money.
What about happiness?
What about happiness and knowledge?
That doesn't make passive income, I don't care.
Yeah, that doesn't make...
Babysit?
If I want kids, I'll just babysit.
Exactly!
It's like renting a child.
Rent a child, and you get paid.
And I get paid, easy.
You stole a child?
No, it's renting a child.
It's illegal.
You can rent a dog in Japan.
I thought that was really cool.
You can rent a dog?
Yeah, you can rent dogs in Japan.
So you can rent them and...
People just let you borrow their dogs?
Yeah, and then borrow them to walk and stuff.
You can rent...
A girlfriend or something?
That's like an attraction.
I want to rent a girlfriend.
You got money to yourself?
Yeah, baby.
A job gives you a lucky number.
If you spend your own, you get 50k.
I let on my own lucky number.
You should get a job.
I just ran over someone.
Let's go gambling.
Raise to increase your salary or get a new job.
Okay, so wait, hear me out guys.
So if I take this new job thing, Does that put me into a proper job?
Or does it put me into a high educated job?
Let's go gambling.
You know what?
My mom told me to be a rocket scientist.
I'm going to stick with it.
So, unlike you guys, I'm going to climb the corporate ladder.
I'll see you guys from the top of my bank account.
It's going to take 20 years.
It's going to take 20 years until you get what you want then.
I'll see you from the top of my bank account.
It doesn't matter.
Alright, spin.
I have half a mil already.
What the frick?
What do you mean?
I didn't go get a job.
I went to get a job.
How did you do it?
It's so stupid.
She's literally living off of me right now.
She's my landlord.
Okay, who's this?
Is this me?
Oh, I get it back.
It's fine.
Oh, she was just borrowing it.
Yeah.
Oh, the bank is giving me bonus?
I mean...
Guys, do your taxes and then you'll get your government check.
Do your taxes.
Chat, am I an idiot?
You can't ask your chat that.
Doobie, am I an idiot?
She's not going to...
She's going to be nice to you, Filly.
Wait, everyone silence Doobie.
You're smart.
Oh, that's manipulation right there.
Why are you manipulating me?
A friend doesn't manipulate.
Doobie, doobie, do you guys know I took an IQ test and got 125?
Okay, that's a lie.
That has to be one of those free IQ tests.
I don't think those are real.
Yeah, I heard a lot of IQ tests are scams.
Doobie, what do you want to do?
Okay, that was really quick.
If you want to pursue...
Oh, thank you.
She was just borrowing 50k from me.
Oh, she got 102.
Okay, Doobie.
Yeah.
Am I smart?
I don't know you well enough.
That's crazy.
Good answer.
That was really generous of you.
I'll be taking that.
You know what, Doobie?
What's up?
Oh, you could get married here.
But it's top speed is still better than your internet.
That's fucked.
Oh, you can get a house.
Wait, you can buy a house?
Yeah.
I literally explained the rules.
You can sell it for 500k.
Think about the sellback.
What a satellite.
What the frick?
She's gonna get 8G internet.
With extra fiber.
Oh, it's my turn.
Oh, I eat fiber every morning.
Solar powered.
Oh my god.
Thanks for the money.
Thanks for the 50k.
You're still there?
I'm getting some back.
Now listen, guys.
You should upgrade your computer for your stream.
I don't need to upgrade my PC for my stream.
Because I'm too busy watching streams.
There it is.
She's retired to be a chat Andy.
Yeah.
Oh, it's my turn.
I'm one of you guys now, boys.
Oh, fuck, who's that?
Oh, okay, it's fine.
I have so much money.
It's like nothing to me at this point.
I'm just here to help.
Oh, no, I might get taxed.
Oh, fuck, okay.
If you land on the red, you get taxed.
But I'm a good person and I do pay my taxes.
And, you know, we gotta support the...
Oh, thank God, okay.
Let's go.
Oh, I get a space scraper apartment.
You get an apartment in space?
I get an apartment?
At the top floor?
I get the suite.
Does anyone know how this game works?
Right now, I feel like I'm losing.
You just have to play it as if you're living life.
Okay, but then what's the point of having more knowledge?
Why am I behind everyone?
Because that's life.
Didn't you say you want to pursue...
You want to be fulfilled?
That's basically...
You're getting fulfilled right now.
You guys are only in it for the corpo.
I'm in it for the fun of it.
See, like, 100,000 bucks for VR.
Visit a VR museum?
Oh, but look at the knowledge.
You might get more knowledge.
Yeah, but what am I going to do with knowledge?
Oh my gosh.
Do a VR every day.
VR museum?
Oh my gosh.
I want to save my money.
She's going to be a content creator on the side.
You already spent a small car on your setup.
Come on.
Get the job done.
All right, Bao.
What's it going to be?
Don't know.
Bonus?
Bonus to fill in.
Did you just run over me?
I might have.
Oh my god.
Esports.
I'm a god gamer.
Oh, all players have to roll.
And then the one with the highest roll wins the esports event.
So you rolled a three.
Check this out.
This is the Among Us Nationals.
Whoever wins is the sussiest.
Oh my god.
Right off the bat.
Check out my apex movement.
That was so close.
Only one winner though.
Why can't I participate in my own sports event?
I have no money.
You did.
You just got last place, Bao.
Wait, did I get 200 bucks?
Yeah, you get 200k.
Oh my god, I'm a rocket engineer with half a million in the bank chat.
I'm telling you, it all comes back.
It all comes together.
You haven't paid off your college tuition yet.
You haven't paid it off yet.
You haven't had to shut up yet.
Let me give you a life hack.
If you press spacebar, you roll the thing.
I am in New York!
If you press spacebar...
I still need to get married.
Wait, she's still there?
Wait, you should get married.
Then you'll be more fulfilled.
Is there somebody you can get a partnership with?
Someone build a tower defense unit.
Um...
Frick, I'm gonna get married.
Chat, listen!
I'm fulfilling my wife-long dream.
Your wife-long dream?
I'm marrying my left hand.
Okay.
I put a dress on her.
Okay, here we go.
Everyone, type one in the chat to pour one out for whoever she married.
Whoever's the unlucky guy.
Wait, I didn't even know what this laser tag battle art was.
Oh, it's like an eSport event again.
Oh my god.
Do you guys wanna see me win big money in the arena against these nerds?
They don't know what's wrong.
Legacy is my actual legacy.
You could've gotten the other one where, you know, none of us get money.
But that's okay.
This is the fattest tent in history.
The one on the left would've guaranteed second place.
Yeah.
I'm higher than you guys, so it doesn't matter.
Oh.
She just loves to gamble.
I'm going for space.
Frick this.
See?
You gave up so fast.
Oh my god.
I got two.
Are you fucking serious?
I'm just so bad at laser tag.
Sorry, I wasn't wearing glasses.
So, like, I just felt bad.
It's alright.
Free 10k.
Can everyone just sit down for a second?
Come on, guys.
I'm the gaming god champion.
Okay, rocket engineer.
Okay, rocket engineer who went to college.
Call me rocket Balboa.
Because I took you guys all out.
Let's go.
Space bar.
Oh shit, who is this?
God damn it.
Oh my god, am I winning?
Am I winning?
Alright, accident.
Let's see.
I can get a better job.
But I don't want to.
You know what?
I don't need to fix my life.
I'm going to go to a concert.
You guys know, next month Doobie, Min, and I are going to have a concert.
You know what?
It's a great time to chill.
I hate my life.
I hate you all.
This is cringe.
Alright, who's next?
Next round.
You're getting married, Fillion.
What are you talking about?
You get to pick.
I mean, you have almost a million dollars.
It's nothing to you.
Yeah, I guess.
Alright, bow.
Oh, you're going to stop anyway.
You're going to have a house or a kid.
I'm going to invest.
This is going so fast.
I told you, this game is super fast.
You want to slow down in life?
Why not enjoy life?
I literally don't even know what's happening right now.
I'm getting married tomorrow.
What are you going to get?
I'm going to sell my underwear.
Oh.
Guys, guys, guys.
You got 80k for that.
Yes!
We're so back!
She got $80,000.
And it's tax deductible.
Oh, that's true.
It is.
Before you make your decision, you got to explain it so that the game can slow down a little bit.
So that we can understand what's happening.
How much left?
I don't know.
Guys, everyone silence.
I'm going to marry either Michael Jackson or this blue tuxedo guy.
I'm going to pick this thing.
I'm straight.
I married a man.
There it is.
Boom, boom, ba-dum.
Oh my god.
He's just sitting there behind you.
Only 20k?
You can tell when she's not pressing spacebar.
Wait, oh my god.
You're so kind.
What a freak.
Oh my god.
We gotta pay 20k for her...
I didn't even want to go to her wedding.
We didn't even get invited.
I would've tweeted long if you didn't show up.
Oh, do it.
There's like a 20k invoice in your PayPal.
Guys, everyone silence.
I just became a millionaire.
Oh my god.
Oh, and she gets a child.
That's fast.
Oh, you can get a pig.
Oh my god.
Get the kids.
They can work for you.
That's true.
Children can work for you.
You can invest in your kids.
You can be like those family YouTubers that are illegal now.
By the way, you should not do that.
Do the funny TikTok.
Come on, little fillian.
You gotta dance now.
But mom, I already recorded 20 TikToks today.
Wait, how am I fitting two kids and a husband on a car?
You got a family car.
I was like, how do I fit this dorm on a motorcycle?
Alright, spin, spin.
Oh, true.
You mocap a child.
That sounds so human.
Human rights.
That's definitely not a human rights issue right there.
I'm mocapping a child.
I just keep paying Doobie.
She's literally my landlord.
Oh, thank god.
I got at least some of it back.
20k and you'll add face tracking to the baby.
Everybody pause!
Wait, how do you evaluate?
How do you stare at the whole map?
I don't know.
Press M?
Maybe it's M?
Is it M?
I don't think it shows.
Maybe you can only do it on your own turn.
Yeah, maybe.
Okay, so you know how you have the little baby crib toys that hangs on top of the crib?
You can replace that with an iPhone so that it tracks the baby's face.
That way you can have full body and face tracking for the baby.
Oh!
Doobie wants to get a pet.
No duh.
Second chance to get married.
They're really pushing that.
Doobie, Doobie, Doobie, get married!
We can marry each other.
Wait, what?
I'll drop my current husband and my kids and put them up for adoption.
She would leave?
She would leave your husband?
We're both blue.
I signed a prenup, come on.
Oh my.
I just got into a yaoi marriage.
Wait, are you gay?
I guess so.
Oh my god.
Why did we have to pay $1,020,000,000?
No, because she got the black space.
We got the red space.
I see.
Wait, so we're just texting people now because we're married?
Yeah, no, it's because you know in a wedding you're supposed to give like gifts and stuff so this is the gift.
Even though we weren't invited technically.
Okay, explain it to me.
It's when you eat hot dogs.
Oh, like Glizzy?
Yeah, the Glizzy goblin.
The guzzler?
Have you heard of docking before?
Shut up!
It's from Interstellar.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna go take a sushi class.
Oh, she can make sushi!
You can use your own tail!
Because it regenerates, right?
You literally cut your tail if you're hungry and then it'll regenerate.
Can you guys see the world map?
You have to wait until the market's good.
Yeah, we can.
So I'm in last place in terms of movement, but I have a million bucks.
Oh, she's over there.
We're literally at the end.
Wait, how am I so slow?
Guys, I took the scenic route, I got married, I had kids, I'm just smelling the roses.
No signal?
She's just enjoying life, you know?
Wait, my effing stream broke, apparently.
Guys, if Fillion's stream broke, there's two other people also streaming.
And you wanna check us out.
No, no, no!
You know, Bao and me, Doki Bird, we're both also streaming too.
Thank God.
Oh my God, I shot a whole bunch of stars.
That's what you do when you're sick.
Am I rich?
You have an action.
You can volunteer for charity, or babysit.
Charity is a great thing.
Let's get more kids in my life.
You'll be more fulfilled.
I'm so filled up.
You know she's really rich if she's not even going for the money option anymore.
Are you afraid, Doki, that I'm giving up the mortal desires of money and income for happiness?
I'm not afraid, I'm just like, well, it's your choice, you know?
Alright, off to the next square.
Online course or continue life.
Oh, I invested in property.
Do you have a house?
Do I have a house?
Yeah.
No you don't.
I live by my car.
I love my car.
Here's your doobie tax.
Here's your fucking doobie tax again.
Oh, a hundred K.
Thank God I paid my taxes.
See?
If I pay my doobie tax, I get a hundred K back.
How do you guys keep getting free money?
Do you pay your taxes?
Um...
Wait, guys, how do I buy a house?
I don't think that's any of your business.
Val, can you sell me your house?
Can you sell things to people?
No, you can't.
Oh, you can watch a documentary about dinosaurs.
You should spend money to make money.
Yeah, but what am I gonna do with sushi skill?
I can't even become a chef or anything.
I don't know.
I chose it just to see what would happen and nothing happened.
Well, in the end, all the stats you get from like the stuff gets converted into money in the end.
Wow!
Stats equals money?
Yeah.
Yes.
I hate college.
Wait, so you're telling me my happiness is just income?
Yeah.
I need to turn my life around.
This is going poorly.
Wait, what are you gonna get?
Oh, okay.
NK.
You can be the engineer.
You can be Fillion's co-worker.
Yeah, let's be co-workers.
Let's go.
Would you trust Would you trust Fillion and Bao to fix your spaceship?
That's like a better question.
Wait, who did you land on?
What space did you land on?
A star.
Okay, but like what number?
Oh, three.
Oh, that's me!
That's me!
Oh, dance off.
Oh, she got eight.
If I lose this, God is dead.
Wait, check this out.
Here we go.
I'm gonna do the yapping.
God, please.
Give me anything.
Oh, she lost it.
She already lost it.
GG.
This is already over.
No, are you serious?
I'm fucking always last.
I took dad's last.
Yeah, okay.
You're so good at shooters.
It's alright.
Third.
Third place, that's fine.
Please, my dad's lessons has to pay off.
Please.
Doobie, you're so close to one mil.
You're so close too.
So far away.
I saw you at 90k last turn.
Most of my money is liquidated.
You know, it's like in...
Oh, it's in real estate.
It's just not paper.
I have all my money.
At the end of the game, do we sell property?
Yeah, we do.
We sell all our property.
And like, see how much...
It's basically whoever has the most money in total.
Fillian, just press space bar.
Fillian, please.
You're cheating.
It doesn't matter.
Can I have more kids?
Investment or family?
Chat, I'm gonna be a Mormon.
We're just gonna have 17 kids and no property.
Even a Mormon has a house.
She's literally living in her car right now.
Yeah, I know.
Me and like 16 children.
It's very rare.
Wait, I get to steal money?
Wait, but car race.
You are so beautiful.
And I just think that whoever married you...
Made the best decision of their life.
And your children have your eyes.
You are a person.
You're the smartest streamer that I know.
Sellouts!
You're all sellouts!
That's what happened to integrity!
Yeah, I know.
You're talking a lot of smack for a piece of candy.
You're a sellout!
What do I gotta roll?
Spin the highest number?
Yeah, spin the highest number.
I've been very unlucky with this one.
God fucking dammit!
You're number one!
But I have integrity!
It's investment integrity.
It's okay, I paid my taxes.
I got my money back.
That's her copium statement.
At least I paid my taxes.
Doki, this is just revenge for Monopoly.
It would be funny if after all of that...
You still don't win this game.
That's all that matters to me.
You just want to see me lose.
I just want to see you not be first in this round.
You're just a full time hater.
Save the person that chose me!
I asked for a comment and you called me a person.
I'm like borderline non-binary.
You're not?
You're not a person?
I'm saying that you're a human being.
But Doobie said I was smart and Val said my children are cute.
Yeah, but do they mean it?
Yeah, of course.
At least I meant my statement.
I know Val didn't mean her statement.
So you'd rather surround yourself with like, yes men who would lie to you.
Actually, if they're women, first off, that was racist.
Second off, they can say whatever they want.
It's America.
We're literally on the moon, Fillion.
This is the United States of the Moon.
Wait,
I'm not even American.
Wait, you're right.
I'm not even a fucking Canadian.
You're Canadian?
I've told you this at least five times.
Ice cap because Timmy's fucking sucks now.
Timbit's quality went down a lot.
Yeah, it did.
I don't get Timbits anymore.
Timbits are not as good anymore.
How to tie my shoe.
One, two...
Oh god, I almost had two million bucks.
My shoe.
Here we go, I'm spinning.
Big number.
Please.
Big number?
Please get her addicted to gambling.
Please, make her gamble more.
Install a solar panel?
You should do it.
As an engineer, you should install a solar panel or you don't believe in what you do.
Doki-do?
I think you're trying to lead me astray.
No, you literally get more fucking stats.
I'm literally telling you, giving you good advice.
Make a scrapbook and put it on my wall.
You don't have any piggy banks.
Can you decorate my picture?
I'm going to make a scrapbook and put it on my wall with all of your faces.
That's when you know she's rich rich.
She has time to scrapbook.
Yeah, I do arts and crafts on TikTok.
That's how rich I am.
Are you fucking...
Oh my god.
This is hell.
At least I get 10.
Oh, I just need two steps anyway.
It doesn't matter.
Risky or safe?
You know what?
This is the only way.
It's gamba time.
It means you can get taxed.
Alright, here we go.
I got taxed.
God, I love gambling.
Let's go gambling.
Oh man.
Does anyone ever call you dooby doo?
No.
Where are you?
And then she'll get copyright striked.
I need you to call me.
Come on, go risky.
Let's go gambling.
Oh, why can't I get that?
That's not bad, okay.
I didn't get taxed.
Not yet.
Let's go, let's go.
Why can't I get that?
That's like action.
It's an action card.
Oh.
Yeah, you get to do family movie night or complete a... that's a fucking expensive...
It's a very expensive puzzle.
It was designed by Van Gogh before he died.
I'm gonna do this one.
King of knowledge.
Okay, primordial soup.
That's me, man.
I don't know.
She's definitely...
Oh, she's wearing weird.
Go risky.
You're at risk versus safe.
You should do it.
It'll be so funny.
She's going risky.
Go!
What happened?
You got seven.
Three, four, five, six.
Yo, she nailed that junk.
And now I'm gonna get a hundred thousand dollars.
Oh, you get another house.
You can pick to...
You have another house.
You can afford it.
I can afford it.
Oh my gosh, she got the penthouse.
That's right, baby.
Why would I live out of a car with a family of four?
Wait, Bile actually might win this.
She has two properties.
That was my strat from the beginning.
Buy all the houses.
She actually might win this.
Guys, why am I held back in the third grade for three years straight?
And you guys are all graduating.
You're the ones that wanted children and a family.
If I don't make it to the end in time, what happens?
We wait for you.
We literally just wait for you until you make it to the end.
We just watch you play.
Alright, bet.
Watch me play by myself.
I'll do a let's play.
Oh my god, back to the let's play era.
Seven, that's a big number, I think.
Yeah, you get to go...
I can't believe you never got extra kids after that.
You didn't even get to the next zone.
Listen to an audiobook or install a solar panel.
They really want you to have solar panels.
I think they're trying to tell you something.
I'm just gonna chat.
What should I do?
One audiobook, two panels.
Legitimately, I like audiobooks way more than solar panels.
If I'm gonna be honest, renewable energy don't matter to me.
I think I'm gonna be dead in like 50 years.
Here we go.
Okay.
That's the message she's sending out to her chat.
Alright.
Alright, I bet you I can get...
I'm gonna get taxed again.
I bet you I'm gonna get... Oh, nice.
Thank god.
I got my taxes back.
Alright.
Who's turn next?
Oh, it's Doobie.
Let's go.
So Doobie, can you tell me some cool black hole facts?
Wait, but she's not a black hole.
Oh, she is.
She is a black hole expert.
Oh yeah, you are.
So here's the thing.
Do you think we can ever escape a black hole?
Or do you think Hawking's radiation is real?
I don't think you can escape a black hole.
We're probably already in one.
We're in a black hole?
That's true, it could be another universe.
We're already sucked up in the black hole, but we never really knew it.
Do you think a black hole can make me taller?
I like how she's playing...
Oh, you know Doobie's getting older.
She's playing bingo.
That's true.
She's almost close to retirement age.
Wait, how old am I in this game right now?
You're like, maybe like 30s.
I'm in my 30s?
Yeah, you're...
No, she doesn't.
But she's like two zones away from us.
And we're almost retiring.
We're literally right next to retirement.
Oh, hey!
You're getting old, dog.
Wait, if you sell now, you can get 700...
You can get like the sell price back now.
Uh, okay.
Wait!
Can I buy your house back, please?
I wanna buy your space shuttle house, please, dog.
It looks sick.
Okay, I'll sell this one instead.
When selling a house, you have six offers.
Okay.
The offer number three is mine.
I just pick any?
Yep.
You didn't pick my offer?
You can try it.
That's my offer.
Come on, take that.
That's less.
Please, please, please.
Let's go gambling.
You shouldn't have taken my offer.
This game sucks so bad.
Hey, you got 10k profit.
Good for you.
Chat, should I go risky route or should I go safe route?
Go risky.
What you have to lose?
You're literally a millionaire.
Sorry, I'm always protected.
Yeah, what are you stressing for, millionaire?
I'm living out of my car.
You can literally get a house.
I'm continuing my life.
Wait, you're still there?
I'm continuing my life, gentlemen.
You're not even close to the house.
I'm continuing my life.
Frick this.
We're never gonna finish this round.
80% of this stream is her trying to spin the wheel.
What did I get?
Three, two, one, explosion.
I have an action.
Oh my god, bowling?
Who wants to go bowling?
Come on.
Let's go bowling.
Bow, you wanna go bowling?
She's gonna risk it.
Doobie, you wanna go bowling?
Doge, you wanna go bowling?
No.
Dude, if you beat me, I'm calling you Doob.
If I beat you, I'm calling you Dookie.
Okay.
Oh, what if I win?
Then I get to call you...
Call me Fart.
I don't know.
Fertilizer.
If she got four, you have a chance.
Fowlian.
What is the streamer luck?
Say my name.
What is her streamer luck right there?
I don't know.
She can barely spin the wheel.
Okay.
Doobie, I won't call you that.
Action time.
Unless you have your written permission.
I'm gonna sell my house right now.
May I call you Dookie?
No.
I'm gonna sell my house.
I'm gonna do it now.
I have to do it anyway.
All right.
That's my Dookie.
Okay, here we go.
No, no, no, no.
You want the bottom one.
That's pretty good.
That's really good already.
I get like a 100k, almost a 100k profit.
I mean, I already saw what happened to Bow.
I already saw what happened to Bow.
I don't want to talk about it.
You want to pick the bottom right, trust me.
I'll take it.
I'm gonna take it.
That's 80k profit right there.
Watch it be like 700k.
We don't know.
We'll never know.
Wait, so you guys are all homeless now.
Just like me.
No, Bow has two houses.
Yeah, I'm just renting.
I'm renting now.
I live on my moped.
Yeah.
So how does that work?
You got like a blanket or something?
She's doing like the van life, but like on a moped.
It's one of those ones that has a blanket.
Wait, you got a tie.
Oh, you get a raise.
I'm gonna get a raise this time.
Is that a $10,000 raise?
You got scammed.
There are too many black hole explorers out there.
It's like IT.
Where everybody learns IT, but now there's too many IT technicians.
Not everyone's IT.
What are the immortality rates of being a black hole explorer?
Because that doesn't sound like a very long-lived profession.
Oh, someone said you can connect a trailer to a moped.
That's true.
Alright, Bow.
Oh, do I have to do it?
Yes, it's your turn.
Can anyone explore a black hole?
Anyone?
Oh, she's about to retire!
Moneys.
Nearly one space away from retirement.
Why do I have a family movie night when I don't have a family?
Because I invited you over to my car.
Aww, I'm godmother.
You're a godmother?
That's free babysitting for her.
That's what godmothers are.
Bow, can you teach my kids?
No.
Okay.
Are you not even sending your kids to school?
40k salary with benefits.
Alright, fine.
How about you start teaching your fans?
Make it up in class on being down bad.
Okay.
What is your problem?
Do you have this shit written down or something?
You know what?
I'm gonna go in then.
Fine.
You wanna go in?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Put me in.
Okay, fine.
Bow, your butt has more fans than your music.
Woah!
Take that back now!
You used to drop an album called The Rear View.
Okay, why is my most viewed video on my channel a music video?
Oh, why is your most viewed clip your butt?
Didn't you start- weren't you like a singer before you became a VTuber though?
Yeah.
Music video pre-VTubing.
Poor game battle.
I literally- That's not fair because I literally retired.
I challenge you all to a poor game battle.
Bro, how is she like- She's so lucky in this.
Oh, JK!
Oh my god, this is the first time I get something that's not the one.
Yeah, that's right.
You scammed us.
What do you mean, you started the poor game battle?
Oh yeah, well maybe I'm bored of this game.
Woah, you picked this game.
Oh yeah?
Well...
Yeah, go on.
Um...
What does that say about your game choices?
My face doesn't look like a- My forehead doesn't look like a poor game.
You're not even like- You're not even like in the screen anymore.
You're not even- No, I'm saying you're literally- You're not even like- Bow, is she in view for you?
No, I'm using her foogie right now.
Don't do it!
You're literally like not even showing up.
Yeah, you're gone.
Yeah, I'm the first one to retire!
Let's go!
Alright, choose pension.
I'm gonna go for pension.
I don't need to be fulfilled.
I'm just gonna be here.
Where are you going?
I'm going to the spirit world.
Did you just die?
I'm in the spirit world now.
Did I just watch you die?
Yeah, I transcended.
Where the fuck are you?
I am in Narnia!
I'm putting a foogie now.
Yeah, I'm literally using her foogie.
She disappeared.
She literally disappeared on my screen.
Dude, literally, I'm...
Okay, let me check if my thing's working.
I think it stopped working.
Oh, it did stop working.
No, it's fine.
Your foogie is funnier next to us.
No, no, don't worry.
I'll figure it out.
Wait, can you give me her foogie link?
I'm fixing it.
Please don't give me my...
No, your foogie...
You're gonna be 2D.
You've lost your 3D privileges.
No, I literally...
Your 3D is too hard to see.
I literally just fixed it, bro.
You've lost your 3D privileges.
I literally just fixed it.
Alright, I'm out.
Yeah, and I hit him now, okay.
Let's go, we're all finished now.
Here.
Oh, god.
No, no, no.
Go again.
Oh, I can't.
I don't have any attempts.
Oh, no.
Girls, girls, girls, check the Discord message.
Check the Discord message.
Bucket list.
Where to retire.
3D privileges lost.
You're now gonna be 2D with the rest of us.
You just emoted me to a JPEG.
Yeah.
We're animated PNGs, technically.
I can't even move my shoulders anymore.
Spin to collect my pension.
Wait, God.
Yo, God-Chan.
Thank you, God-Chan.
Alright, Fillion, your turn.
You see, you see, you call me fertilizer, but my profile picture is- Oh, my God, I'm almost 2 mil.
Wait, I hella- Yeah, I locked in.
Wait, you made it 2 mil?
Oh, wait, no.
No, no, she's still 1 mil.
But with the Ray Fillion's going, we might be 2 mil.
No, no, no, no, guys, I'm gonna do the math.
See if it's a 1 now, it turns into what?
Here it is, conversion.
A 1 turns into a 4, so I'm gonna stroll a 6, and then turn into a 10.
Come on.
Risky or safe?
Go risky.
You can get a house in risky.
Oh, yeah?
Well...
Do you want a house for your family?
What gets me more kids?
Risky.
That's literally what I mean.
I wanna risk it.
One risky, two safe, what do we do?
I think safe doesn't give you children.
That's all I'm gonna say.
It's true, I don't believe in protection anymore, I guess.
I don't know.
Risky?
Anymore.
Risk it, risk it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's the worst that could happen?
Girls, I did the math.
A 1 turned into a 4, so a 6 is gonna turn into a 10.
Watch.
I can't even click on this stuff.
Okay, here we go.
Easy 10, easy 10, easy 10.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I was close.
Doobie!
Oh, the doobie tax.
Thank you.
You can have a chance to have a house or pay taxes.
Or kids.
Do you think I should book a mall?
Oh, kids!
There's a chance for you to have children.
Watch this chat, watch this.
So if I go and put it right here, and when I press space, it's gonna put it into kids, watch.
Am I the only one that heard that?
Am I the only one?
No, I heard it too.
But now I don't want to enable her.
That's crazy.
Wow.
All that shit talk about my ass.
All that shit talk, and then she had to pay taxes.
That's unfortunate.
That's so unfortunate.
Did you know the IRS caught up to me this year after three years of evasion?
Oh, hey, look, another 100k.
Hey, hey.
Single moms be like.
Wait, I'm actually catching up to Fillion now in terms of money, pension money.
Please.
Someone please catch her.
Anyone.
Hey, Doobie, you're almost retiring.
I'm almost at the finish line.
Oh, you're almost there.
You're almost there.
Thank god, Fillion.
Play Sudoku hard, Grandma.
Chill out.
This is fucking lame.
Wait, Doobie, Doobie.
Can you hop on a monkey bar anymore or are you just too geriatric?
Oh, I'm too geriatric.
My knees are gone.
Oh, no.
What happened?
Donated them.
Arthritis.
What happened, Doobie?
It's the gravity, space gravity.
I lost in two black hole incident.
That's true.
I can't believe.
If I could travel back in time, I'll go back and kill Isaac Newton.
So we won't have gravity anymore.
He doesn't want to live in space or earth.
It's because of him for inventing gravity.
Wait, Doobie, I almost caught up to you.
Really?
Yeah, I'm right behind you.
If I roll a two, I catch up.
Alright.
We should not let that happen.
See you later, Grandma.
So I rolled an eight.
Watch, an eight turns into a ten.
Alright, we're watching.
Eight turns into a ten.
Oh, hey, look, a three.
Oh, but you caught up to her.
Wait, and you get paid.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Time to roll.
Aw, 10k.
Fuck, okay, that's fine.
I got 200k anywhere earlier.
You're just getting money from rolling?
Yeah, if you retire first, you get...
You just wait and roll.
So you just get a bunch of money?
Wait, you caught up to me in money.
Yeah, exactly.
I'm going to lose.
Damn it.
Oh no, taxes!
Oh no!
Taxes!
Doki, I...
Frick you.
Also, Doobie, if you ever have too many taxes, you can just jump in the hole.
Okay, that's good, I guess.
Like, I'm not the only one that's retired.
That is true.
I'm going to walk into the nursing home and steal your bingo cards.
Bingo player is Doobie right now.
She's not retired yet.
I'm going to put laxatives in the tapioca.
Oh my god.
You know what you actually get?
I will leave the stove on with mail on top.
You know what that's called?
It'll be an old woman in a crotch chair running away from a fire.
That's called elderly abuse and you can go to jail.
What if it's an accident?
Doobie, you know a little bit too much about elderly abuse.
You see?
Grandma's on the loose again.
The third player to reach retirement.
Yay, you retired.
Now what?
You need to do a bucket list.
Oh, bucket list, hell yeah.
And just keep spinning.
See what you get.
Am I last?
No, no, no, no.
Listen, guys, I can do the math.
You have nine knowledge and Bao has six banks.
Which means it's wasting my time.
So if I want to win, I go for knowledge and money.
Yeah, you go.
I'm going in for my pension, baby.
What happened to not fulfilling your life?
Well, it turns out I wanted to see you die.
It's my last mission.
It's like a bunch of retired people in a nursing office together.
I'm scared of you every day.
You literally abandoned your husband and your kid.
My kid grew up and he was a furry.
So I did what I had to.
You literally left your husband and kid for a pension.
You went there by yourself.
I told him I had a job to do.
And I looked at you and I'm like, say my name, doki.
To your husband?
You looked into his eyes and say my name.
We're good.
Alright.
Our last spin, Bao.
Our last retirement spin before...
We're all gonna get doobie taxed.
It's okay.
Are you still there?
It's just doobie.
There's no way you get a one.
There's no way.
Don't say that.
You gave yourself money too.
Oh, okay.
Congrats.
That's 300k.
Okay, I'm gonna pick the other one.
Since you guys all picked that one.
Let's see what happens.
Oh, you're going to the black hole.
She literally went to the black hole.
Oh,
you got nothing.
What was that?
I think Fillion won.
Did I?
Yeah, I think you did.
This is like the total money you get.
But you also get like bonus stuff.
But like Fillion had the most...
She fulfilled her life a lot.
Oh, okay.
You know what?
Who's holding the bonus?
Oh yeah, she got the bonus.
I hate Mario Party.
Alright,
that's enough.
That's enough for you.
Alright, I have to remake the lobby.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
You gotta remake the lobby every time.
Sorry, I'm out of the lobby now.
So I'm not part of that game anymore.
We're doing a new lobby right now.
Alright, so what map do you guys...
We have Haunted Hills.
We have Frozen Lands.
Sandy Shores.
Under the Sea.
El Dorado.
Superhero World.
A normal?
You want the classic?
You wanna be a normal person?
Yeah, doobie pick.
I'm sorry, what were the options again?
I literally won the game.
Fairy Tale Kingdom.
Haunted Hills.
Frozen Lands.
Sandy Shores.
Sweet Haven.
Under the Sea.
El Dorado.
And Superhero World.
What is Sweet Haven?
Oh, is that like sweets and stuff?
Yeah, yeah, it's like candy then.
How about Fairy Tale?
Oh, Fairy Tale.
We already have a jester here, so...
Yeah, we already...
What about the normal one?
We'll do normal one.
Are you trying to say Fairy Tales are normal?
No, I just like saying like...
Ow, frick.
I'm just saying, ow, frick.
My headset's spinning.
Oh, frick.
The normal one, no one's ever done it before.
The normal one is like...
Maybe there's a reason.
Yeah, maybe there's a reason why no one does the normal one.
The normal one did win, so...
If you wanna play the normal one, just turn your computer off and extend your real life.
Just go outside.
Just go outside and play the normal one.
Does anyone wanna buy me a real job?
No.
Okay, if you guys quit streaming and became a normie, what would you do?
I'll do what my degree was.
What was your degree?
Whatever it was.
That was not a helpful answer, dog.
You should've said when I was saying your degree.
Whatever it was, I'll do what my degree is.
Okay, so...
If I was not a streamer, I would join a maid cafe.
It's my humble dream.
And I would serve people coffee.
That's just like a barista.
That's just a barista, yeah.
But I would be in an outfit.
In Japan, I would move, I'd be like, Nihongo.
Okay.
I'd be like, Kawaii.
You know.
A girl can dream.
That's why it's called a dream.
Sorry, I haven't joined the lobby.
Don't worry, Doobie.
Nobody has joined the lobby.
We were listening to Filian's dream.
Filian's dream that might never come true.
Don't you guys wanna share dreams for a little bit before we get back into an entire another game of life?
Wait, this is my dream.
Streaming was my dream.
Okay, fine.
Then I'll ask a different question.
Would you rather fight a hundred dog-sized horses?
How come after I say my dream, we go to a different question?
We didn't even hear the other people.
Why try and no one answered me?
Doobie, what would you do if you weren't streaming?
You moved on before we could.
You ignored Bow and Doobie before they could say anything.
I'm more brave than a picture at this point.
The slime TikToker.
Oh, a slime TikToker?
ASMR Squishy.
Slime ASMR?
That's genius.
Okay, okay.
Do you know people who made slime stuff?
They made so much money.
It's profitable.
It's still profitable, too.
That's because women don't know how to spend money.
What?
But we're all women.
Filian, how much have you spent?
I'm a good example.
A billion.
Filian.
What does that say?
It means that I don't make good decisions.
Okay, so I'm going to tell you this is a fact, okay?
We know that.
Women are probably worse at driving than men.
Why?
Because I've only been in one accident while driving and it was my fault.
Statistically speaking, I'm breaking down the average for women united across the world.
It would be fucked up if this month is women's month.
Pikmi sweets?
No, this isn't a Pikmi sweet!
Okay, well then...
Filian's a Pikmi girl!
I bought a Pikmi!
I'm not like other women.
What is a Pikmi?
Everyone point to that.
What is a Pikmi, bro?
Is that the name of a plant?
The bird of Pikmi from Dark Souls 1?
Pikmi?
What is a Pikmin?
Yeah, you can say it like that.
Pikmin!
We have to lobby out.
I would be a farmer.
Oh, a farmer?
What kind of farmer?
I don't know.
I think I'd want to have like a petting zoo.
And then I would have like a TikTok for it.
Oh, I've seen those farm TikToks.
Can we do stuff without TikTok?
It might be banned in America soon.
With ducks, right?
Yeah, the ones on Twitch.
Where they put streams of animals and stuff.
That's really cute.
And you can feed them too by sending biddies.
That's my exit plan.
Oh yeah, build a robot that when it gets bits, it just releases crumbs onto the ground for them.
That's so smart!
That's what some of them do.
If you donate biddies, it sends food out to the animals.
Belle, Belle, can you hire me?
Put the robot, I'll do it.
He's on the walkie-talkie.
He'd be like, they sent in the pumps, we'll throw them out now.
Are we waiting on one person?
Oh, I see.
I can tell when Doobie looked at her monitor.
I don't know if you saw it, but the moment Doobie turned her head and looked at the monitor, she was missing.
I just like clicking on stuff.
Okay, Doki and Belle's chat, give me a one if you just want us to talk for a little bit.
You know, as friends.
We can talk while we game.
Alright, alright.
That game time is for combat.
Okay.
Billion cat multitask.
Actually, as an entertainer, it does make it hard to multitask when you're trying to think of stuff to say.
You know what I'm saying?
You have to think?
Um, alright.
Do you not have to think when you talk?
No, it just comes out of my mouth.
That's impressive.
That what you've been saying is what you've been thinking about.
Chat, the code was 8694.
Idiots.
Okay, I'm ready.
Wait, can I not be pink?
Oh, I'm pink.
You change your colors now.
You clutched, you clutched.
I'll be brown again, chat.
What do you guys think?
Brown for fertilizer.
Yeah, brown for fertilizer.
Yeah, call me fertilizer one more time and see what happens.
Which one was fertilizer?
You know what's cool about fertilizer?
It makes plants grow.
Yeah, it's made out of cow shit.
Okay.
What do you think?
Cows make methane, which is good for the atmosphere.
No, it's not.
That is not.
Well, cows are good for the atmosphere in general.
Guys, this is why we need to eat cows.
To save the environment.
They're my favorite animal.
We gotta eat cows to save the environment.
Who the frick's a skateboard now?
That's Bao.
Why are you yelling at me?
I'm sorry.
Wait, she has a car now.
Look at that car she has.
Heck yeah.
Guys, go to college with me.
Come on.
Okay, I'm gonna go to college.
Alright.
We can join a...
What's it called?
A sorority.
Oh yeah!
Frat house.
Have you guys seen those sorority welcome videos?
Where they made it like a welcome to hell.
That's crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
She's crazy.
And then they make it a final boss.
Oh.
Oh, you get to order takeout or another board game battle.
100,000.
You wanna challenge me to a board game battle?
We're already fighting each other?
I have not rolled less than an 8 on these mini games.
I have not rolled less than an 8.
I remember you fought me once and then you lost.
Yeah, but I rolled an 8.
You rolled a 3.
I rolled an 8.
Thank you.
There you go.
See, watch.
Bam, easy.
Close enough.
Pick your time.
Hey look, I love one.
Bow, don't you wanna be one with me?
We could get third place together.
Oh gosh.
Barely made it.
How do I get fourth?
I always win.
Guys, guys, what are the secrets?
Put my camera back on your stream and we'll see what my secret is.
We made it.
Put it back on your stream and we'll see what my secret is, okay?
Alright, let me know when you did it.
I did it.
What do you see?
What should I say?
You never requested me to say it.
I see you.
What am I doing?
You're being cute.
Okay, I'll stop.
Fine.
It's hard to freaking do it.
She's strong.
You could be a fairy.
I could be a fairy?
You're so small, Fillion.
Fillion, what are you doing?
You're just standing there.
A furry?
What's the song from Peter Pan?
Neverland?
No, that's not.
I don't think people remember any songs from...
She was a fairy.
Alright, I'm gonna become a fairy when I grow up.
If you steal my job, I'm actually blacklisting you from my entire life.
You have to attack this as a fairy?
Yes.
Who established the government here?
The king did.
Also, just so you guys know, 8 is my favorite number IRL.
How does the king control the rights for fairies?
Okay, guys, I'm a fairy.
I move one square per turn.
Oh, guitar lessons.
You should.
You can play like a tiny guitar.
It's not a guitar, it's a ukulele.
Well, it is a kingdom, like Doobie said, so a king lives there.
We should start a rebellion, like the French.
Let's do it.
A tower guard gets paid less than a fairy?
What the fuck does a fairy do?
I get paid 10k less than a fairy.
Bro, all you do is stand in front of a doorway.
What the fuck does a fairy do for the people?
I am doing my Tinker Girl C, you know what I'm saying?
Yo, okay, listen, Doobie, when you're a fairy, are you not out there tinkering your bell?
What are you saying?
Because I value her opinions.
Leave her alone!
I don't know what you mean by that.
Are you out there tinkering your bell as a fairy?
You need to leave us alone!
You're like the Na'vi.
Hey, Link, listen!
Anyone got a fly swatter around here?
Did you guys know I'm attracted to electricity?
You're like an electric fairy?
Yeah, I'm like an electric type Pokemon.
Oh, bowling duel.
Bell, what do you say?
There's no way a fairy loses a bowling duel or wins because I'm like four inches tall on a good day.
Fine.
Yeah!
Put her in the jar!
Wait, Bell, check this one out.
Alright, alright.
Oh, what is it?
You got fucking finessed.
This is why you don't make deals with fairies.
What the heck?
I won!
You wonder what a fairy do?
A fairy is a real hustler.
Yeah, I know you're a scam artist.
Yeah, and I'm also rich right now.
Listen, I ain't even gonna call it I'm rich.
We gotta fucking...
We gotta put her in the jar, guys.
You know I'm gonna get a jar for this, Koogi.
I'm gonna get a jar for you now.
Just cause you said that.
Fairies go in jars.
Exactly, that's how we...
It's like trolls.
We put the trolls in a jar and then eat it.
Woah, I'm gonna be a mage.
Oh, a mage.
That's kinda sick, actually.
Cast spells and stuff.
That's actually kinda sick.
What the frick?
Yeah, I mean...
She went to college for that.
She went to magic school.
Koogi, I'm so sorry.
I'll give you your money back.
Alright.
Don't put me into a napping bird.
I'm gonna put you in a fucking jar.
Can you polymorph me?
What spells do you know?
Why are you still trying to put me in a jar?
You're a town guard.
Go defend something.
I didn't go...
I'm not a guard.
That's the thing.
Then what's your job?
I'm an oracle.
I can predict the future.
Oh, so now you're a professional scam artist.
No, I'm literally...
I'm literally an oracle.
Here, I cast a spell.
You can spin again.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
Yeah, you wanna get a really low number like golf.
Okay, I'll see you later.
Doki, I'm gonna do your job for you, okay?
Here we go.
Is her job fake vaporware?
What the fuck is that?
That's really embarrassing, honestly.
Yeah, that's pretty embarrassing.
Watch me roll a low number for Doopie.
That's pretty embarrassing right there.
I don't really have words.
I failed you.
If you think about it...
Six is an upside-down nine, which is still pretty good.
There we go.
You know what?
I think you fit right in now on my stream.
Why?
Oh, I don't know.
What did you do to me?
Maybe you should pull up my stream and see.
Okay, maybe you should put a girl on.
Yeah, I rolled a three.
One, two, three...
Okay, I'm gonna go pull...
Cart race?
Or upgrade my PC?
PC, baby.
Okay.
Take it.
I will.
I don't think I won't.
Oh, you have the most wealth now.
You're so wealthy.
What did you do to me?
Are you on YouTube?
What do you mean?
Where are you?
Where do you stream?
If you're asking that now, I'm not telling you.
I'm gonna Google it.
I found you.
You made your stream title.
I'm gonna do...
G4 Gore.
What did you do to me?
You're gonna run out of air in there.
There's no air holes.
Can you see this?
I'm gonna start a family.
Let's go.
I want you guys to pay 20k.
I'm gonna make sure you guys...
No, not taxes!
Can't escape.
Not even in fairytale.
And I have to pay taxes.
I made sure there's no air holes in here.
Sorry, little guy.
Sorry, fairy.
What is this?
I just poured water.
Where did she get water?
Where did she get water in the jar?
Where did the water come from?
It was empty when I put her in the jar.
You can be a mage!
If your name is Smith, then what are you?
I'm gonna be a mage.
Wait, isn't Anubia a mage too?
Oh my god!
Who's the better mage?
Oh, thanks for the money.
I have no money!
Why am I poor?
She went to a fortune teller.
Oh, another laser tag.
Let's do it.
Chat, I'm a fairy.
Yes!
Oh my god, that's not fair!
You're a mage!
No.
No, I bet it's if the other person has to agree to it.
I don't agree.
I'd rather keep you in the jar.
How about a good deal?
That is a good deal.
If I win, you take me out of the jar.
Yeah, and if I win, you put yourself in the jar.
On stream.
It's a deal.
Mom, prepare a jar JPEG if I need one.
She doesn't even believe in herself.
She told her mom to get that ready.
If you believe in yourself, you wouldn't even...
I've had the worst luck in these though.
I've had the worst luck in these.
Are you fucking serious?
I won!
Alright, I put you out of the jar.
You know, I just miss on the best joke of all time because I won.
You know, you can still do it.
Yeah, but do you really want to lose out on content?
Yeah, your chat's commanding for a jar.
100 memberships and I'll...
...go to my channel...
...and...
...100 memberships...
...and I'll put Philly and back in the jar.
100 memberships and I'll...
...put her back in the jar, guys.
100 memberships and I'll fill it with mayo.
Oh Yes, I know you Shake it That's my channel
Thanks guys for the memberships everybody, thank you
In a jar, guess Billy's going back in the jar
Forte do you want me in the jar doki in the jar final answer?
I think people are gonna pick you fill you in Nah, that's oh, hey.
Thank you guys for the fifth.
We're the hundred months Thank your buddy back in the jar
Oh my god, wait, oh we all page when you we're all paying a doobie 20k Were we invited to the wedding doobie?
The thing is
The thing is if she gets divorced she can get another marriage and then and then get 20k from us again In this game, oh my gosh, I wish that we could oh My god your first house Wow Congratulations, oh my god, you should get all your guys Homeless.
Oh my god.
It's going she's getting a farmhouse.
She's living your dream bow You told her your dream and she stole it from you
You oh you're you're gonna hire balance the fire You can work on my farm
Wait fill in your your stream is a mod it you should not tell your stream that it there's no mines They're gonna no, no.
No, okay.
They're gonna run wild
He has a jar you can send it to her I can send you my jar, okay
Put me and not you in it
You actually sent it oh, it's a semi one Yeah, but my sister you should use my jar cuz it was like the continuity is better immersion So it's like when they look at my stream and then they look at your stream, they'll be like, oh, it's the same jar It's fully immersive Oh My god,
what am I doing your turn?
Jar tree isolated on PNG, bro The funny thing is is you've been in a jar my entire stream Why am I gonna charm everyone stream I'm too strong I'm too strong for my jar Okay, buddy.
You keep telling yourself that I have to stay still now.
You can't roll around everywhere.
That is true.
Actually, I'm kind of stuck
What is my life Can I get out now no we shake the jar We should is it possible to shake it let me see yeah shake the jar
I'm always get the doobie tax.
All right, I will get
I chose a one guy.
I chose a woman.
All right, what do you mean?
Why?
I Give me your 10k.
I wish I could divorce them so I can farm another marriage Farm another marriage
What I'm doing gold digging you guys Okay, I got children too, all right, that's fine I should know I won't pay I want I want pets and then you're gonna steal
Oh my god, you got quick with a big green dog.
Oh my god, I gotta die Nice Buffy, why are you so happy?
I don't know because I have a fucking dog I was too busy putting my jar in this one choosing to get married.
Oh, all right.
How's that chariot?
It's my little marriage opportunity.
Yeah, it's like the shrek chariot Watch this Oh a job A raise or a job.
I'll make a raise What?
Okay, fine As a fairy I deserve to make more than a wizard You must take it up with the king you're not even like the same height Do you have any magic in you Like light up.
Oh, oh no, you're like you got tags electricity Do you know how many tier threes are approaching my jar?
It's a very stressful profession here Why am I asking you just exist It's weird.
You're literally like a collectible right now.
Okay, you're like call me an effing funko like a funko pop.
Yeah, you're like a funko pop Call me a funko I just ran over 40 000 bucks.
Oh, oh, you got a job You keep guys Time for me to forsake my jar It's a time for you.
Are you really gonna I thought you loved being a fairy What happened for it You're perfect You know what?
Let's see what the cards hold for me.
Here's this check this out.
Watch this i'm gonna become a master wizard also Here we go.
Watch We'll be a Hey, there you go
This is not real Oh my god, it's your dream job
Dream Oh my god go entertain us now Okay, i'll guys i'll tell you a joke.
Here it is.
All right All right Oh, no, I can't make the joke on stream.
Um Okay, wait.
Yeah, you're gonna get executed Okay Think about your answer before you say it out loud, okay A man walks into a bar He says out Oh the game's gonna street gonna spin your wheel for you.
He told not during your absence a computer has replaced me It's all right, I still want you long enough to mess up now I got taxed too What was the joke Bar he says ouch ouch Oh Like that wasn't very funny.
Okay, guys, I got an even better joke.
I think you're oh, that wasn't very funny
Doobie wi-fi
You know, maybe we should execute her I think so too.
Maybe she's not a very good jester.
I think she's not No, yeah, she didn't dance for us, right you're right Goodbye Goodbye cruel world.
It's okay.
Your taxes is gonna help the health care in the kingdom.
Great I'm gonna get the plague and die before that happens.
Oh a dragon We gotta throw tomatoes at phillian's chat throw tomatoes at her that was a bad joke your brethren at me Started throwing tomatoes
Okay, why was no Okay, then Um, okay.
What did what did no.
Oh my god.
The doobie tax is going strong That's crazy Made just money That I don't have to give birth You could have got a dog Yeah Most important aspect.
Yeah, the most important aspect a dog Don't don't don't let her yeah, you wouldn't say that Don't pick her.
No, she doesn't need more money.
She's always winning.
You always get a high number I'm not gonna make you Oh, wait, what happened?
Oh, we gotta spin again.
No, we gotta prolong this hell Oh, thank god, there's a chance.
Okay, it's over.
There's a chance over there's an oh, thank god I won probability You don't take it from me, right?
You just get it from me.
No, I didn't See you guys this is why I didn't go to college I stole it from she went to the fortune teller which was me and I paid two and she got scammed Okay If I roll over a 10, you guys all have to laugh There is nothing over 10, there's nothing over 10 You see this is why she didn't go to college This is this is okay there watch Pretty high It's pretty high.
Oh my god That's good tax.
Yeah, you got the doobie tax I didn't really use the head for once you did it.
No, I got a whole body.
No, call your family You should you should invest in your future.
You can come up with better jokes.
Yeah.
Oh true.
That's so true doobie that Okay, here we go I don't need children.
I don't need a husband wife kids.
I don't I am I watch anime.
I'm cool.
Oh my Don't tax me Oh, she got 50k How was that run oh my god, that was a god god roll for her.
Oh, I didn't need it.
Okay That's right.
Will your dirty wagon into the village?
Come on, join me.
I want I know I do want a house though I don't want a house I want a house Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, I do get it Nice Nice All right time to buy a house Oh 450k and I could sell it for 900 I got the hobbit house.
It's the lord of the you're you're not even a fairy anymore.
I have a joke for you guys I have a joke for you guys.
Yeah Okay, why can't the police find the hacker?
Why?
He ran somewhere
Tomatoes guys, remember the throw tomatoes at the gesture, everybody
Tomato tomato Did you get that one from chat?
No.
Oh, that's like
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back.
So it's not my fault I'm so happy With my beautiful elf wife elf wife elf wife And lucky Do you guys ever play skyrim nor yeah, what'd you play what race?
And there was a cat I played cat too, yeah, you're playing that right now, that's true You know some people I don't know the more things change the more they stay the same, you know what i'm saying No We live in a society Okay
I don't like that joke, bro All right, here we go.
All right doobie Yeah, oh don't break toe.
That's my turn.
Okay.
Thank you david duberk Shh I made a name for a collab.
Do you want to hear it?
Yes It's called dobo doolean That just sounds like a human centipede our names It sounds like a yugioh doobie in philly and dobo doolean dobo doolean.
You know what?
What do you think?
Oh my god, you're gonna die I came back for a puppy Oh Nice now you feel more fulfilled.
Yeah.
Oh wait, I upgraded to a car.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah car in the house Ladies watch this with this sacred treasure.
I summon eight-handed divine sword figure legendary marksman to Oh, hey a three yeah domain expansion Oh, you can go on a road trip Knowledge, you know what?
Knowledge audio books, baby.
Yeah, but you can get a manual you can gain real life experiences though on a road trip So have you guys ever had an uber driver who just put on audio books that are talking to you?
What?
No, usually i'd be like don't talk to me I don't know No, like on your uber you can like say you don't like to be talked to Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, so I do that because I was like, I don't want to talk to you Yeah, what no it's any uber Yes, you yes they do Updated your app.
Yeah, you must not have updated your app Yeah, you can literally pick drivers who will be more like Talkative or not and I choose an option to like don't talk to me.
Yes Because i'm like i'd rather be on my phone Yeah, same Yeah.
Yeah Are you talking to people in a new area though?
I don't mind talking to like I visited florida and I talked to the uber driver and he was like Yeah, we see alligators on the road and we run over and stuff To be fair it is florida I'm, literally rich.
Well, you can get a hermit's camp and be anti-social for real Nobody will ever visit you I'm safe
Wait, have you still not got a house yet?
I think like just fairies aren't allowed to have houses.
I'm a jester You could be a fairy jester not allowed.
Yeah, jester is definitely not allowed
Yeah this is during the the dark times we're like Well, technically like jesters during the medieval times.
We're like smart individuals Technically exactly.
They're smart and clever and they know how to make jokes.
Well, I did say usually Okay
Interesting, what is a candy house, but you bought an effing graham cracker
Don't worry, you'll get your house here filly and I believe you'll get the house graham cracker Does polly want a cracker?
I'll sell you mine Yeah, i'm down 500k.
Whoa I've never had a s'more before Never had a s'more.
Oh, I want s'mores.
It's like marshmallows with graham crackers, right and chocolate Chocolate.
Yeah melted chocolate.
Yeah, I've never had it be fresh Wait fresh marshmallows.
Where am I?
Yeah, like it's on fire and then you blow it out and then you put it in your mouth Yeah, yeah.
Yeah guys.
Should I get a new job?
Well, you don't want to be a jester.
I thought you liked being a jester What if I get an education too if I stay this effing circus prick Maybe you'll be a plague doctor.
I thought yeah, I don't want to be a jester.
I haven't made you guys laugh yet It's just like but eventually you'll get there Painful ones you just need to get more experience billion If you quit early never quit too early, you know, like that meme where like you stopped and then you don't get the diamonds That's not my parents.
That's you It's you right now you're quitting before you hit it big You think yeah Eventually, you'll make one of us laugh big.
Okay.
All right.
I'll be the best jester ever serious Look, look, i'll be like no, it's not even a funny joke.
Yeah, 90% gamblers quit before they hit it big I'm about to hit it big check this out Right here filly and this is it i'm gonna make a name for myself you're gonna you're gonna hit you're gonna hit your your mark Let's do this Okay, press play bar take your time Seven that's me bonus,
baby.
We're back see Are you winning it might be first place?
No, i'm back baby and she's gonna get him.
She's gonna be a single mom.
Let's go
Get a single mom, wait, let me think what are you thinking about?
Yeah, i'm almost dead already.
Frick.
Yeah, let's get some kids Oh my god, she's gonna be so fulfilled How much money are these kids worth?
Well back in the medieval times you can actually sell your children.
So That was the thing.
That was a thing.
It was like three shmeckles in the game I don't know.
I don't know.
You gotta sell your kids to find out.
Why am I?
Oh my god.
I hate the government In this game in game in here, I hate in game I hate this I hate the kingdom Dude I am so lucky.
Oh my god big wall It doesn't matter you have to stop Times now
Yes, i'm gonna get my phd, uh-huh.
Yeah, she got phd she got better education
Yeah You can't escape it Can't escape the doob tag just got a million bucks.
Oh my god.
See look at that college works.
Oh, here we go All right chat, this is it yes if I can oh my god her luck is turning around it's happening i'm cooking Here we go.
Oh my god.
She's actually cooking here we go.
Here we go.
Here we go big numbers big numbers Do you guys know what the opposite of zero is?
Seven Seven This is a joke My wife's a joke We know.
Oh my god.
I'll never i'll never succeed in these fucking events
I'm gonna i've just been hitting the space button.
It's been doing well Yeah, but apparently i've also been hitting the space.
That's cursed All right, here we go here we go Yeah, maybe I should spin it Oh, no, my turn to get cursed now Doober tax incoming not the doobie tax.
I'm taxing.
Yeah As I laughed at your joke damn it paid me to come to your party for your kids Have you guys seen those videos of the austin powers impersonating Me Oh, I haven't I don't know risky time Oh frick, oh you got chance so you can get taxed again.
Oh you lived fate What is maybe now i'll get it Oh, you can get a raise Get a raise.
Oh, that's a good raise.
Yeah.
Yeah That's a good raise that's like 20k All right, can I get a raise Got that on that square.
We can raise you on to the highest shelf and leave you Oh, come on I wanted a big number watch this watch this.
Oh, you're at the stop, baby.
Wait, i'm so far behind now.
No Chat i'm a single mom.
Do I play it safe for the kid?
But you can get a house on the if you play it risky.
I can see a job in my future You don't want a house for gift.
Yeah, you're your child's homeless Chat, let me see about the mortgage my child for a house.
You technically can back in the dark ages Yeah, but you skip everything what you skip all you skipped all the houses
Wait, you can graduate You want me to educate myself now, yeah Chat i'm gonna swap profession for the third time in my life, please.
Do you want to be there for your kids?
Yeah, you're a single mom.
You gotta make more money for your child silence When I grow up i'm gonna become a level 99 mafia boss.
Watch this a bigger jester I literally went to college.
Please the court.
You got promoted to the court
Oh Do me a power majors Everyone's done me already, bro Level up who the frick is black.
Why am I smithing him?
I'm going with that one.
Frick that It's less money But it's less money come get your armor Oh my god.
Thank you.
Oh, it doesn't matter every time.
It doesn't matter All right, oh you guys are past the zone, yeah, it's fine No, no, what is it?
God wait, but you just got your degree.
How do we know it's a good sword?
Because um, it's curved I don't think swords are supposed to I don't think swords are supposed I get taxed again.
I can't Oh my god.
I I think I paid taxes like three times or four times.
This is my fourth tax You know what?
I'm fucking i'm fucking starting a revolution Okay Yeah, someone's gonna die that's like a real war in power.
Yeah, i'm gonna predict the king's gonna die in 20 I'm gonna do a j-slot and say be careful in 20 26 january 3rd Something's gonna happen to the king You
Who's the dragon tamer they should tame the dragon into it.
Okay.
All right.
I'm getting a live action soon.
So Okay Wait, I'm about to finish life.
I'm gonna die
Chat what happens if I die You retire Why oh my god, we pay doobie and doobie has to pay philion Keep my wife's name out your effing mouth Who's your wife?
Oh, thank god.
I'm not the only one getting taxed.
Wait.
I thought you didn't get married Okay,
here we go guys i'm about to finish out my life, let me see i'm at the very end.
Oh my god i'm catching up I'm gonna finish all my life forever.
Yeah, but then you get less chances to do Goodbye Everybody goodbye
You paid her back you paid her back Boys, i'm going to the great beyond collect bonus.
Oh, you guys first player.
Hey, i'm rich you could do a bucket list now What does this do?
Oh Fulfill your life fulfill your life.
You did pension before don't you want to seek fulfillment?
Yeah, well, you're fine.
I chat I grew up as a fairy Then I made bad jokes and got fired I started making swords and no one bought them So, you know what?
I'm right up in the sunset and i'm spinning for life Am I living out of a tent yes, yeah you are By the way, that's the worst choice you could make because you have a chance to like Yeah, but you you get fulfillment but they're like 20 points what does any Oh,
maybe you could use more hearts.
All right.
Yeah, I guess yeah, but each of the fulfillment is like 20 points versus 100k
That's why you don't want to be awkward No, i'm fulfilling my life.
You guys are jealous i'm, so jealous You guys are jealous of my life being fulfilled Well, how fulfilled do you feel yeah, how fulfilled my life is very full.
Thank you Also, my name is phil.
So it's already part of the job job I could throw a barbecue party guys who wants to go barbecue with me?
I don't have a job Who wants to go barbecue only people with jobs can join this bar
Why call it a barbecue instead of a jarbecue What's the jarbecue what i'm in right now?
Oh, do we just grill you?
It's good.
She's hot boxing herself.
I'm getting grilled.
Anyway, what's the difference?
You're getting steamed.
You're getting steamed fresh berries.
No, that's bao I'm gonna play it safe because i'm filet filet lablao.
No doobie tax the doober tax It's inevitable I swear she's just making income passive leave off all of us.
Yeah, that's my passive income.
That's her passive income Dance off let's do it.
Oh pick me.
Do I make money off this?
Yeah, you do i'm gonna bust a move.
I won she won It's over Why does she oh my god, what are these rules?
I'm not even a competition big dance moves Are you serious
Wait, we all have to spin again.
Oh wait.
Oh because you got oh my god Because you can't share
Okay, please please please please why was six separate about uh, because 79 7 was a six offender Spin this junk i've literally heard you say that before it's not funny.
Okay.
Come on, man Yeah, that's what you deserve right there.
That's definitely what you deserve right there That's i'm rich Nice dreams, maybe
All right, i'm so far i'm not catching up No, there's still hope you could just pull a huge scamba scamba scamba Well, I don't know.
Oh, no doobie.
Yeah, doobie's gonna die Hey, yay Hey Oh, you can sell your house now.
Oh, you can sell your house And does anyone want to buy?
Yes me.
I offered you the top left.
That's middle Bottom right is my offer top left Okay, come on.
Come on.
Come on Doobie, I would give you 250.
I'm retired.
I got nothing else to do Fulfill your bucket one.
Wait, is this low?
That's a 24k profit
Come on Oh, wait,
how much did you pay that's so good 76k that's really good easy That's pretty good.
Yeah, we take those your pension.
Yeah, so you can get more money It'll be a while till I make it so you guys are definitely getting more money I'm like so far Chad do I have a chance anymore living my life?
Is it over?
Well, technically if doobie keeps getting 10k you have a chance to win again Okay, but but she just needs to get rolled 100k And you get to be fulfilled Congratulations.
Oh, yeah lights.
I've been starting this thing for like five years now I love lights I'm the best thing about it is that there's no more doobie tax because she died What wonderful news wait, does that wait?
Oh, I can't tax you guys anymore.
Yeah, you can't That's the best part.
Oh, but I guess I get taxed by bow No one visits me No, I'll visit you doobie I promise We're the lottery.
Oh my god.
I need this Come on, I need the lottery It's fine, what's your favorite food?
It's still 20k.
Apple fries.
Oh good.
I can cook that.
Okay good Yeah, we're fine.
We'll do that.
God.
Okay.
We're just we're just oh, thank god.
Look you're like you're almost a millionaire now You don't need this I am now a millionaire.
You're almost you're literally a millionaire now Sunglasses i'm going to get gigantic sunglasses.
Yeah That's cute.
Oh, you have the most wealth nice Wait, how do you have the most?
Oh the piggy bank?
Okay.
I was gonna say how do you have the most wealth?
You're not I just kept picking things that gave it to me.
All right, don't worry guys.
I'll be there very soon I'll take your time.
It's okay Oh There you go, please end it anyone so my doobies more rich than a billion now, that's me guys i'm cutting my jar for this Space bar
Nothing Just stayed in the jar What was the point of retiring that's what a lot of americans are asking
I like it I can you want me want me a mini golf, please.
Let's see.
Oh, I can challenge you guys Pick me No, you're you're your probability is way too good
That's probability is good too and I want doobie to beat philly so I don't want to take money What is the closest to beating you?
about All right Here we go You literally won last game philly Oh, thank god if I won, thank god.
You're still a millionaire.
I'm not just last game You literally won last game philly But that doesn't mean anything.
Oh, wait, I can finally retire.
I'll just pay you back for my monopoly
Oh wait bow can also have a chance to win I offered you top left bow that's still me Goddamn, frick you.
That's pretty good.
Actually.
Wait, that's 91k.
That's really good Okay, we're back 100 subs Oh, you owe two Oh my god, we got 49k you got like a almost 200k profit.
She's so rich.
Wait, she's literally She's gonna win I think she wins these.
Yeah, she actually wins I'm so far away.
Let's go.
Yeah, this is this is a statement be single and alone American dollars what the frick she's literally she doesn't even have a cat to be the cat lady I Don't worry guys i'll be there soon Dollars she literally won the game and won life.
Oh and she gets a hundred One life I lost the game No, don't worry.
No, I am so far from everybody I got taxed by the fucking king like four times No What did I roll?
Not as many times we got taxed by doobie.
That's true.
The doobie tax these lies for three years.
I can't see anymore I guess All right, here I go don't worry guys i'll eventually make it over I'll get there soon Oh I did I got it All right time to pay off my house I love the sky All right halfling house, oh Oh, that's like 100k plus.
Oh, that's 100k Nice That pretty good.
Okay.
Can I even spend one time for my pension?
Would they let me?
All right.
Goodbye.
Goodbye wife and kids I never needed you.
Oh, thank god 100k.
At least I get 100k out of this Oh my god At least I got the bare minimum Guys let's find out here it is I was a fairy total money Doobie's not just gonna take a while
Really close this game.
Oh my god my attributes
Winner yeah
Congratulations, what can I say dragon tamer in the land?
Wait, you have a scrapbook.
The first drop was an oracle and that was it.
Okay.
Yeah That's why you gotta go This is a statement to go to college and then bow one Wait true and then I didn't go to college.
She won because she went to college.
Yeah, I got a master's degree in dragon taming Are you crazy?
I don't want to pay the college tuition Oh my god, I can see why you're a youtuber.
We need fourth again.
This is the first fourth place chat What's third last time?
Oh, all right, do we do one more normal perfillion
Normal map that you really wanted I don't want to be a normie now
Chat one for one more game.
What do you guys think?
I don't want to be a normie You want to go to college?
Why don't we all go to college?
We should all go we can all be classmates.
Yeah, we can all be classmates.
We can do study hall Guys, we can make content together as roommates Okay, wait not about that but like Yeah, I don't know Videos or something in our room.
I don't know about that one.
What I do bro like what?
All right, I posted a lobby code Okay, bet.
Okay.
What if I play?
What if I click online with friends?
Um enter a lobby code All right, who's gonna be the first one in here?
It's been very consistent No, no, no everyone slow down let me it's been very consistent on who's gonna be here first No, no, no, no.
No, I can do this.
I can do this here.
Well, nobody's in yet I'm gonna be a normal person now.
No, no, no, no I Did it?
shoot well Well bios first Doobies for a second.
No, no, no, no, no It's not even letting me enter the code, bro I told you it's been very consistent It's not fair.
It's not fair I posted it in the same group chat for everybody And the unit mark zuckerberg was downloading my data and he was bitcoin i'm gonna Those are a lot of words funny, man Okay, i'm gonna dress.
Oh i'm gonna go i'm getting rid of this.
I'll make sure I have my outfit for college Oh true.
Should I be a crab chat?
All right.
I'm ready for college guys What should I do me too i'm ready for college let's go Oh Oh, I didn't oh my god, I can be a kawaii girl.
Frick.
Yeah Okay guys don't be alarmed but I am very cute all right, oh you're ready for college you're also ready for college Let's go everybody starting care.
I'm gonna be sick.
You look like an art major.
Thank you.
Let's all go to college everybody Wow Did you guys know that artists actually make zero dollars?
Unless you're like a artist on like twitter That is deviant art or that or for you Surprisingly a lot of money That is true.
Yeah, you have to freelance though.
You have to own your own business Okay, doobie doobie goes through again Dolbert
We all agreed now we're gonna get normie jobs
Oh Welcome to the college experience, let's go
Why did I click that I'm gonna party too million drugs to me No, i'm going to college.
I'm going to college.
Here we go.
We're all going to college.
You're gonna be sick nasty.
I'm with you Yeah, let's all go to doobie's party.
She wasted 100k on it Yeah, guys, please.
What do you what did you even do at the party that cost 100k?
That's a lot of alcohol Uh, i'm selling goodie bags, too.
If you guys want to buy.
Oh, yeah, they had a mike tyson.
There's like appearance There's like yeah, there's like 30 beer Beer pong tables.
Have you ever played beer pong, but without alcohol?
What a film director?
Whoa No, it makes less than an app developer.
I'm gonna guys call me michael bay Oh god, what's your lucky number number three?
What kind of films are you making?
Yeah, what films?
Oh, yeah, what films are you making?
Does it involve a couch?
No Okay
But it was my first movie That's awkward that's awkward I didn't I guess your career died that fast you ever seen pacific rim Yeah, yeah, that's a great movie Oh, oh you would have made so instead of getting del toro.
They wanted to get you They oh bro, they were asking for me, but I was like, i'm still in college so like so they dodged a bullet Oh, that's not Wait, why are you challenging doobie?
She's broke already.
Oh, I was no it's the bot.
Oh I'm, sorry.
I'm gonna challenge you but whatever happens happens Now we're enemies now.
Yeah.
Yeah, well then beat my eight She's literally You put her in the dead
This is her first time meeting you and you fucking took her out
It's like my play and I made this I was pretty sick Well, I feel like everything Finneas said, he knew what to do today.
Yeah.
Nothing we can do about it.
Someone's like, she do be broke.
Do be broke.
Oh, you guys can both be film directors.
No, that's okay.
That's okay.
No, thank you.
No, I'm good.
You guys make more than I do.
I direct movies.
Will you let me star in a movie?
Well, you have to make good movies first.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, I can't get another job already.
Alright, but will it be better than a chef though?
That's the thing.
Come on.
Let's go gambling.
Can we do it?
Chat, let's go gambling.
Chefs are cool.
I mean, they are.
Aw, dang it.
You know what?
I'm gonna risk it.
It's time to get a new job.
I know I just became a chef.
I just became a chef, but I feel like...
I feel like I need something new.
I realized I got the wrong degree.
Oh my god, you know what?
It's less money.
It's like 20k less.
It's fine.
The game in charge...
What game are you gonna be in charge of?
I'm gonna be in charge of...
Let's see...
The crypto game we were talking about?
Yeah, we gotta get a good game.
I'm gonna be in charge of Lethal Company.
That game is still good.
Right?
Okay, wait.
Doki, hear me out.
So you direct the game.
I'll direct the movie adaptation.
We'll make a billion dollars.
And then...
What is...
Oh, these guys don't have jobs yet.
We'll put them in the lead actor roles.
Oh, Ryan Reynolds.
We gotta get Ryan Reynolds.
We should get Ryan Reynolds.
Yeah, Ryan Reynolds.
Yeah.
Isn't that...
Dude, we gotta have a word on this, Joan.
We gotta get Ryan Reynolds.
And then, we also have to counterbalance Ryan Reynolds.
So we'll get The Rock.
And then, we'll get...
We'll count...
And then, so like...
Wait, we don't have money.
Doobie needs loans.
Doobie, I'm so sorry.
It's too real now.
Oh, and she has to take another loan.
No, it's fine.
I know you gotta step on somebody.
Didn't climb the ladder.
It's fine.
No, it...
Don't worry about it.
Oh, my God.
You haven't graduated college yet?
She truly is just like...
Yeah.
It's time to throw a really good party.
And you even went to her party.
You went to her party and took her money.
That's...
Bro, it's not my fault.
She bet me $100,000 on a bowling game.
Oh, but you can be an engineer.
You can make battle bots.
Dude, don't be a battle bot.
My life's turning around.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
It is.
Look at that.
You set up drones.
I'm free.
Oh, I can go to her party.
Watch me.
I can go to her party.
Go party.
You have such good connections like old times.
Yeah, dude.
You remember the good old days when you threw that party?
That was so fun.
Oh, that was such a good party.
You gotta...
I'll do it again.
You're gonna have a realistic party.
All I'm saying is ever since that party, your life turned around.
Now that my life's turned around, I'm gonna throw another party.
Now that I don't want anything until I hit rock bottom.
Sorry for party rocking.
I'm an addiction.
I feel like the AI's gonna move for you.
To be honest, the AI plays better than I do.
Who's that?
Oh, my God.
See?
Doobie, I panned you back.
You know, I only owe you 50k now.
See?
All part of the plan.
Thank you.
Ran you over.
Ain't no party like a Doobie party.
Yeah, man.
What the fuck is 100k for takeout?
This better be like some Michelin star shit.
Yeah, it's Gordon Ramsay.
You pay him to fucking cook in your kitchen.
20k.
Nice.
Nice 20k.
Why did I get one fourth of my payment for the lawn mowing?
You just didn't do a good job.
That's a lot of patches.
Yeah.
Oh, what is that?
It's fate.
So I can get taxed again.
Oh, phantom.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Yeah, but can I afford it?
Can I afford it?
Oh, I could take a loan.
You know what?
It'll be worth it.
It'll be so worth it.
Look at the max price.
I know.
I'm gonna take a loan.
You borrow money from the bank and you pay him back slowly.
Exactly.
I'm getting a mortgage.
Yeah, yeah.
It's fine.
Is there interest?
Yes.
It's okay.
I'm mortgaging my house.
She's mortgaging?
I see.
It's so worth it.
It's fine.
If Doobie can be in debt, so can I.
Take a loan.
Take a loan off.
It's fine.
Just like life.
Yeah!
You almost got out of college.
I guess I'll just always get money.
Wait, are you still in college?
I think so.
Are you...
Instead of like...
Do you wanna slam dunk me?
Instead of three years, you're in the six-year route.
I'll just do this.
Good bet.
Board game battle time.
Here we go.
Alright.
Someone beat my six.
Not Doobie.
Alright, it's Fillion's god roll time.
God roll time.
They called me.
No!
Stop copying my answers!
Oh, thank fucking god.
Look at that!
Paid off my debts!
No!
So easy.
How do you actually pay off your debt?
When does that happen?
I think it happens at the end.
I'm pretty sure.
Or like, your next turn.
If you have enough money for it.
I don't know.
I've never been in debt before.
In game.
In game?
In game!
To be fair, I went to a Canadian university, so I definitely haven't been in college debt.
Ain't that nice.
Stop!
Free?
Stay single or marry women?
If you get married, you can make everybody pay 20k.
That is true.
And you can get out of debt again.
Okay, time to cheat the system.
Chat.
What should I do?
Shit.
Who did it?
Oh, it's Filian.
Why are you always paying?
You're robbing me!
Yeah, you're robbing her!
Bro, I still owe 100k!
Oh my god!
I can't believe Doobie is dead.
I'm gonna die with debt.
I'm gonna owe 100k to my children.
Don't worry, maybe they'll send a check.
They'll send a severance check.
I think what the game meant by normal was exactly like real life.
Just say like real life!
Doobie, I'll put you in my movie, bro.
Maybe we shouldn't have gone to college.
Okay, yeah, I'll pay you 100k.
You're a film director, you should stay single.
Okay, I'll stay single.
Chat, should I stay single?
Just grind a bunch of money to buy Doobie's debt out?
What do you guys think?
Wait, didn't you put her in debt?
You're gonna buy me?
And then that way you can throw an even bigger party.
I'm dedicating my life to saving Doobie's life.
You know what I'm saying?
That's a good cause.
I'm giving a party so I'm not gonna waste it or anything.
The party life is behind her.
Are you sure?
You give her like an allowance and she just uses it.
Oh, you can get a job?
Get a promotion or...
Okay, Doobie, I know I said I'd put you in my movie, but I'm busy.
I'm sorry.
She's having a midlife crisis.
Party!
Okay, no, no, no.
Don't worry, I'll give you...
You can be...
Oh my god, video games or robotics?
Look at the money.
Chat, what do I do?
Do I do it for the money?
Well, Doobie became a robotics engineer and then she went into debt.
So, like, there's that.
Yeah, it's bad luck.
Doobie, I'll partner up with you.
We'll make a really sick, nasty cybertruck.
And then we'll take it over the planet.
Okay.
We'll do it.
Oh my god, you guys are gonna make a real Transformers.
We're gonna make Megatron IRL.
Also, I gotta go pee, I'll be right back.
Megatron...
Actually, I said that, but Transformers aren't actually robots.
They're like...
They're actually, like, aliens.
Oh my god, I already paid 50k.
Alright.
I'm gonna get married so I can farm money.
Every year.
Is there any downside, really, to getting married?
I guess...
That's what the game wants to trick you into believing.
I have to pay taxes again.
Da piggy bank.
Got taxed.
I just get taxed.
Can I please finish college?
No way!
I'm still in college!
I literally have just finished.
Hey, maybe you have your doctorate now.
Oh, you'll be a chef!
I'll be a chef.
Maybe it's your passion versus mine.
I didn't like being a chef, but...
Oh, that's Billion.
She's AFK and she's farming passively.
It's like farming.
You're never gonna finish this game.
It's okay.
Oh, wait, you get to keep...
Oh, wait, you're back!
Wait, you caught up!
I'm back!
Let's go.
Oh, Moe the Neighbor's Lawn.
Get that 80k.
Is that one of the people you're known for?
Oh, seven.
Isn't someone you're known for using the bathroom quickly?
What?
What does that even mean?
Who's that?
Maybe the chat knows.
Maybe the chat knows, yeah.
Is that you?
I'm very fast at it, yes.
I'm gonna pay taxes for so long.
Do you have a race?
I don't think I want a race peeing.
You can do that.
It's competitive, it's competitive.
Competitive bathroom.
Alright, time to farm income.
We married!
Beautiful!
Yeah!
EL!
Alright.
Heart.
Oh, banana, oh.
It's time to spin to collect.
Oh, fuck, okay.
You guys like Pop-Tarts?
Yeah, I've never had a Pop-Tart before.
I do like Pop-Tarts.
Okay, what's your favorite Pop-Tart flavor?
I like the cinnamon one.
Ooh, okay.
Right now, I will say, if you haven't had a Pop-Tart, you're missing out big time.
Oh my God!
Your life is turning around ever since you got married!
Your husband is good luck!
You know what that means?
Another party.
Another party time.
Another day, another party.
Yeah, now you have...
Thank you.
Your number is 10, by the way.
I'll grab one.
Oh my God.
That's a number.
Here I am.
Can someone stop giving her money?
Anyone?
When will she pay taxes?
I think I've seen Philly and paid a tax.
I've never paid taxes once, and I've never owned a house once.
Therefore, I'm gonna get a house.
That's beautiful.
Forget the family chat, I'm all about the house.
Woohoo!
Yeah, baby!
I'm rich!
Okay, check me out.
Where's my house at?
Woohoo!
Okay.
What the heck?
I just got a job.
Boys, where are we moving in?
Boys, are we moving into a luxury apartment or a family?
Frick that family.
I'm gonna live in an Andrew Chang apartment.
I'm gonna say, like, you don't have a family.
Like, who's gonna live there?
Yeah.
This looks like a bachelor pad.
Exactly.
Why are you making me feel like Batman?
Wait, Batman at least has Catwoman.
I have a luxury apartment for Catwoman.
For what?
For yourself.
It's a bachelor pad.
You can be a passport, bro.
What's even the point?
Jacuzzi, true.
I'm... please.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I was gonna stop anyway and get married.
Alright, women time.
Another day, another farm.
She loves me for me and not for my money because I don't have any.
At least now I know.
Oh, thank God.
Pay me 20k, everybody.
What?
Pay me 20k.
Please, I have...
Holy scam, bro.
Okay, well, guess that's your dead body right there.
I should never make any friends so that when they get married, I don't get taxed.
That's true.
I mean, you can literally not go to their weddings.
Don't go to their weddings.
You know what's the worst part?
And we still get taxed.
The worst part is destination weddings where they make you pay to go to a fucking country.
Yeah.
That's like a lot.
Yeah, there's like destination weddings.
You have to fly there and then...
It's basically a wedding where it's not in your country and you have to pay for your own flights.
Jesus Christ, why?
Exactly.
I've never been to a wedding in my life.
At best, you get like free food, but it's like, is it really worth it?
If they tell me their effing wedding is in China, I ain't going.
In fact...
I don't know, I'm just gonna delete their number.
I bet if you like...
Went to...
Can't you just like...
How do you save money having a wedding?
You don't.
You could just have a courthouse wedding.
You don't save money.
No, I don't wanna save money.
You marry Jeff Bezos, no prenup, then you break up with him.
I mean, that's what his ex-wife did.
Exactly.
Did you know like 8 of the top 10 richest women in the world are from divorces?
What am I doing wrong?
How do you know that fact?
Like, why are you even looking up that fact?
Were you trying to do something?
BALTAX!
RARE BALTAX!
Oh my god, the rare BALTAX, yeah.
Oh, we got a house!
Oh, what's her house gonna look like with under 130k?
Oh.
What are you gonna get, Doobie?
The family house!
With your family!
With your husband!
Your BL husband.
Her husband.
Out of money.
Not a loan would hurt you, Doobie.
Not a loan wouldn't hurt.
Yeah.
Wait, can everyone get married except for me?
I haven't gotten married.
Oh, okay.
Are you gonna get married, BAL?
I don't know.
Okay.
I will next time.
BALTAX!
RARE BALTAX!
One!
Alright.
Oh, you get a second chance at love!
Frick that!
Okay, so I just wanna sell a house.
But you just got a house.
Frick yeah.
Alright chat, let's get rid of this bad boy, baby!
Bruh.
This is what I've all been waiting for.
Listen, girls, I've decided that...
I realized that living in a big box had no purpose.
And I don't wanna do it anymore.
So, I will be taking your offers.
Which one should I be clicking on?
I'm too poor for this.
Bottom right.
I can't afford a luxury apartment.
Also, Doobie, I think you're muted.
I know!
Doobie, which one are you putting in?
Stewart.
Oh, she's muted-muted.
What's going on?
Alright, fine.
She said...
Foul!
I'm trusting you!
You got 800k?
You got the max profit?
Foul!
How could you foul?
How could you?
I don't know!
Foul!
She's already rich!
It pays to be single, ladies and gentlemen!
No, it pays to be friends with me!
Look what she did to Doobie!
She can't even talk anymore!
I'll give you the check.
Hello?
Welcome back!
Hi!
Why did I ask Doobie to do that?
You skipped my purchase offer.
Oh, for 320?
Is it worth it?
Yeah, but I could get 560.
Oh, this is...
Oh, let's go gambling.
Oh.
Oh, wait!
That's better!
Let's go!
Yeah, let's do it.
She profited, boys!
I profited!
That's 100k!
That's all that matters!
Mula!
Okay.
She Doobie back!
I'm whole, and I'm happy.
Okay.
What just happened?
Oh, no!
Oh, oh, oh!
Yeah!
Oh, the civilian tax!
The rich gets richer!
Dog, I came into rich from smart real estate investing.
It is what it is.
Investment.
Oh, you want to get another house?
I know that house faster than anyone else has.
Doobert.
Oh, the Doobie tax.
Oh, she's making it back!
I really, really need money.
Ever since she threw her first party in college, it's never been the same.
Oh, she can buy...
Oh, we can buy an island home.
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, my God!
You bought a holiday home in Europe.
Why do you have a swimming pool next to your house on the ocean water?
Because the ocean water is salt.
So, she wants a chlorine thing.
What are you mad about?
She wants a chlorine water.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to be clean.
Yeah, and she consumes...
And poop in the water.
Exactly.
The ocean is nature's toilet.
Oh, no.
You lost that.
Oh, you get a kid while having three loans!
No, no.
Yeah, kill a three-year-old!
I think that's a bad idea, maybe.
She's trying to be a robotics engineer.
Get a pet.
Yeah.
Oh, you got a cat!
Hi, hi!
Yeah.
How are you this broke?
And a full-time mom.
Yeah, she likes to party.
How are you this broke?
She's here for a fun time, not a long time.
My husband supports me, okay?
Yeah.
That's true.
Oh, okay, yeah.
Jeff Bezos strat.
No, he's also in debt.
Guys, I'm speedrunning my life.
I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty...
Her husband is, like, a house husband, too.
Bam.
Give me something good.
Oh, two!
That's pretty good.
120k.
Guys, I'm effing...
I'm drowning in bands.
She's really speedrunning life right now.
Okay.
Alright, bet.
Bet, bet, bet.
Left side was investment, right?
Okay, investment.
I already...
You know what?
I don't know if I want to get taxed again.
I don't know how to pay the government more taxes.
You didn't get married?
Casual?
I already...
Yeah, I got married.
Casual?
Alright, let's see.
What?
You know what?
I'm gonna risk it.
The government needs more money anyway.
Wait, so I'm confused.
I never understood.
Why do you have kids in this game?
Do they not turn into money?
They do.
They turn into...
They turn into $20.
They turn into $20?
Yeah, you just get $20 off your child.
That's terrible, bro.
What does the dog turn into?
The dog turns into $20 too.
They're in the same level.
Human equals dog.
No.
No, no.
A child equals a dog.
Oh, a child.
Oh, yeah, that's fair.
Because, like, if you think about it, when they're children, a dog is smarter than a child.
That is...
That is true.
At least a dog can, like...
At least a dog on an airplane doesn't have to be a child.
I don't have to change a diaper off of a dog versus a child.
I don't need to feed the dog.
Well, I do need to feed the dog, but, like, the dog can...
You don't feed a dog.
No, the dog can eat the food themselves.
I don't have to hold a spoon for it.
They can hunt for their own meal.
Oh, true.
Astronomer.
Oh, my God.
That's true.
Let's go.
What?
We're going to space again.
We're going back to space.
How does staring at the moon equal 200,000 a year?
What are we even doing?
I'm forgetting when the sun explodes.
You're just feeding the Libras and Scorpios.
You're gonna find one of the black holes.
You're just astrology-ing people.
You're gonna find a black hole and drive the Earth to it.
Are you playing Omni-Man gameplay?
Oh, my God.
I have two.
Oh, you're so...
Oh, you sell your house.
Oh, a retro video game.
That's pretty sick.
Yeah.
Let's get video games.
Video games.
All right.
Guys, I'm gonna roll a 10, reach the retirement home, and then just die.
Four.
Okay, fine.
We're all doing low numbers.
One, two, three, four.
And check the lottery ticket numbers.
Bro.
How is she so lucky?
I do not need any more money.
She literally...
My life is money.
She literally siphoned off of Doobie's luck, and then she's riding high.
I watched Doobie, that's not me.
She went to her party and just, like, took everything from her.
Guys, I'm on my Sigma groin set.
This is just like real life Fillion.
Bro, if you think I'm rich, you gotta get your brainstem checked.
That's it.
I'm going online college.
All right.
I want...
I want a better job.
How much money have you spent on your stream?
On my stream?
Right now?
Today?
Oh, yay!
Oh, I can be a strawberry, too!
We can...
We can both find that black hole!
Let's go.
Let's go!
You wanna talk telescopes or what?
Oh my god, we can both find that black hole and make sure the Earth gets sucked in.
Perfect.
That's my dream right there.
I think I got taxed.
We'll give them the coordinates, but after...
Yeah, we'll be like, it's okay, I got taxed.
Dang, I...
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
I'll never leave.
That's Ashley Ashe.
I love the government.
Two girls, one moon.
Wait, so I have never gotten taxed this entire game yet.
At what point is it evasion?
Like, the first time?
I'm getting taxed more.
You're gonna get audited after this stream.
Nuh-uh.
Oh, second chance!
Ooh, marriage.
You like, finally fulfilled your business life and now you're...
And now you're looking into your...
She disappears.
She could be a gold digger.
She chose you after you became an astronomer.
I'm the gold digger, actually.
Cough up 10k.
At least it's not 20, okay?
That's true.
Wait, so why can't we marry each other?
We can't.
It's a conflict of interest.
Yeah, it's a conflict of interest.
We're competing in life.
Yeah.
We can never be together, we're all vtubers.
Yeah, we're all too competitive.
Ooh, six.
Wait, who's that?
Bowtax.
Oh my god!
Oh, Doobie, what happened?
What do you mean?
What happened?
I need to invest.
That's on yourself, big guy.
Oh, thank god.
Her dead life is turning around!
And she gets a house!
And a house!
I'm gonna buy another house even though I don't have any money.
350!
Bro, the Doob back is real.
Holy frick.
You could've gotten another loan.
She Doobie back!
We have three loans!
No problem, I'll be able to pay him off at the end.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You'll see, you'll see.
I believe.
With all those houses, I believe.
You guys watch Arcane?
No, I haven't.
No.
Because I don't want to play League.
I heard if you watch Arcane, it's gonna make you play League and I'm afraid of that.
You can be a dog.
You can get a pet, yeah.
Oh, you're the cat lady!
I'm gonna train this into a Pokemon.
I'm gonna see how many fights I can win.
Oh my god.
You're gonna be a cat lady.
Oh, come on.
Did I get a cat or a dog?
You're gonna be a single cat lady.
No, you got a cat.
Single cat lady.
Yeah, that's you!
You could train it to throw bricks on people like that one dog.
Oh, yeah!
I heard about that.
What the...
Renovate my... I'm gonna throw a barbecue party.
I don't need renovation.
W party.
Let's go.
Oh, my turn!
Wish I would land on myself.
Boom!
This music is all I can hear in my brain nowadays.
Oh, yeah, baby!
Woohoo!
To be honest, is being a single cat lady that bad?
It's not.
Free money.
Seems alright.
It's not, but like, if there's an emerge... Oh, you can train your cat to dial 9-1-1.
You can?
Yeah, you can.
There was like, there was a cat.
I watched a YouTube short of some guy that got like, a heart attack.
And then the cat dialed 9-1-1 and saved him.
He like, trained his cat.
They're really flippant.
They might not do it.
The cat only dialed it because he was gonna have no food otherwise.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, exactly.
Because he thought that the cat didn't learn.
And then, because he was trying to make him learn.
And then he wouldn't do it until, like, he got a heart attack.
And then he actually dialed 9-1-1.
How does a cat dial 9-1-1?
Give me your money!
Wait, what?
You distract...
She's like, give me money!
Doobie's like, it's the moan shark time.
It's time for mine to get my money back.
Okay...
You fucked me over.
She's brass smelling it.
Doobie, put down the gun.
She has six loans.
Put down the gun, Doobie.
Shave your beard.
She broke into your house and was like, give me the...
I'm back, baby!
Another spin round two.
Loser!
You're never gonna get your 100k back.
You're never gonna get your...
She needs the money, it's the least you can do, you bajillionaire.
Get it straight.
Just like Bezos.
Just like Bezos right there.
Doobie is like the Amazon worker.
This is compensation.
When you drugged me in college.
And made her throw all those parties.
Forced you, like...
You, like, convinced her to throw all those parties.
Billion.
I'm not the one that did all that stuff, bro.
Yeah, but you're like...
Bro, it would be so cool if you threw a major...
If you threw a ranger right now.
Okay.
You were like, whoa, Doobie.
It would be so funny if you threw that party.
Look at that, you literally made half of that money back.
Just ran her over.
Oh, you should be risky.
Frick yeah.
Yeah.
What does risky do?
You can get a house.
I'm gonna get a house.
Ask me anything.
If I end up on tax in the night, I'm gonna be pissed.
Oh, that looks bad.
No, you don't.
You can still get taxed though.
Nuh-uh.
Yeah.
To be fair, she's been so lucky.
Oh, she got another pet or a child.
Dude.
Why am I becoming a crazy cat lady?
You're a single mother.
Or a cat lady.
Maybe you'll get a dog.
Yeah, maybe you'll get a dog.
Just give me a second animal.
Frick this dog.
Oh, you got a dog.
A pupper.
Why is he green?
What are you gonna name him?
You don't just ask a dog why he's green.
I'm gonna name him Greedo.
I like how you have like...
You got two dogs and you're like...
I gotta get a new car for these pets.
Oh, nice.
One.
Oh, I can build a tree house.
Oh, I wanna build a tree house.
That's kinda cool.
Yeah, I got my own tree house, guys.
Okay, here I go.
Another 10.
Oh, it's green.
Okay.
Do you really need another house, Bao?
Yes.
Bao, invest in another house.
I'm gonna invest in another house.
Ooh, duped.
Okay, she duped me.
Dupy tax.
And I'm not a cheapo like you.
Yeah.
I'm gonna lose all of it at the end anyways when I have to pay off my loan.
Fate.
Alright, will she have to pay taxes?
Yeah, baby!
You remember that raise?
You didn't spin, Bao.
You didn't spin it, yeah.
Oh, I thought I did.
Yeah, baby!
Even better.
Oh my god.
It's just that easy.
Guys, I think I'm a sleeper winning this game.
Holy shit.
I am!
I think she's sleeping on this game W.
I'm not gonna lie.
Watch it be doobert.
Alright, don't worry.
It's okay, you're gonna have to stop anyway.
Bao just might kill John Lennon after a little bit.
I'm gonna lock in.
And then y'all get the online course.
Come back to college.
Oh, okay.
I don't think that's a good idea.
Why not?
Imagine all the cool parties you can throw online!
I'll be tempted.
That's why.
On Microsoft Teams.
Through a master's degree!
What?
Through those parties.
I like how they were pushing you to get another degree.
They were like, are you sure you don't want to go to college?
What did you just say?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wait!
She's so back!
Wait, she's back!
I'm back!
She's actually back!
She's questionable back.
We need to be determined.
Where the frick are we on this board?
Wait, she's almost there.
I should've never helped Fillion get that max amount.
How do I... here?
No, here's the thing.
I don't have any actual prospects in my life, so...
I only got money to my name.
That's so sad!
Yeah!
You have a cat and a dog.
You have a cat and a dog, yeah.
Exactly.
You have some purpose.
And you get another dog!
And another cat.
Get another cat!
Do it!
Another cat.
I'm not adopted a kid.
Okay.
Get another cat.
No!
What should I name my third cat?
Name it after a chatter, yeah.
Okay, I'll name him...
Fillionfan119.
No.
Oh my god.
TinyHawker!
Oh my god, another cat!
Yeah, TinyHawker!
Good job.
Look at you, living your life.
Alright, W-Hawker.
Let's go.
Now, don't you feel so much more fulfilled?
Yeah, don't you feel fulfilled now?
I spent my entire life shoveling poop.
Yeah, but if you had a kid, you gotta change three times more diapers.
I just had no kids or dogs.
You would have to clean so many diapers.
I don't... I'm not gonna... I'm not... I'd get taxed.
I can feel it.
I'm tired of getting taxed.
She's so tired.
I'm so tired.
You know what?
I'm gonna take a guided tour.
Yeah, I'm gonna go around the world in 80 days.
Nice, finally.
Easy.
She's gonna go to space again.
Yeah.
Chat, are we good?
Okay.
I'm never getting to the finish line.
Okay, I'm gonna get some sunglasses again.
Awesome.
Your sunglasses are cool!
Thank you.
They look good on you.
This is my most low-numbered spins.
Oh, six.
Just take me to retirement home already.
I think Chow might be winning this game.
Take you to retirement.
Oh, you're back!
You got 100K!
Let's go!
Remember, this is it.
The end game.
Alright, watch this.
I slam home this 10, I make a million bucks, and I'm out of this video game.
I ride to the sunset!
Oh, it's almost there!
Let's go!
You got your money back!
I'm out, peace!
Oh, but you retired!
See you nerds later, baby!
I'm out, baby!
You wanna be more fulfilled?
Nah, frick that.
I spent my whole life fighting for the bills.
I'm gonna stick with it.
Well, you left your pets, though.
You left them!
I gave them to Peeta, they're fine.
You left...
Oh, you didn't wanna give it to Peeta.
You abandoned all of them!
I gave them to Peeta Mallark!
Woo!
Bro, how?
How is she?
You know what?
She did organize this collab, so she might be...
Oh my god, are you serious?
She might be rigging it.
You guys know I can actually hack video games?
Bro...
Can someone else choose the game next time?
Bro!
Yay!
Yo, white buddies!
Where's my buddies?
Oh, the lottery!
Oh, play the lottery!
Frick yeah!
Oh!
You know...
Wait, how did you make money when losing a lottery?
What the frick?
I made some money by...
No, it's like she didn't...
She got like five of the numbers instead of the rest.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, well...
Frick, this game is cheating.
It's not real.
You are literally retired.
Like, what do you...
Well, I wanna do but have opinions, okay?
You made 100k and you're complaining?
You know what?
George Bush, I don't like that guy.
And I don't like Obama either.
There it is.
And I'm an old woman.
I can say whatever I want.
Frick.
I don't know, man.
She is retired.
And somehow her vote still counts.
We're still here.
You know what?
The bad thing?
Economy is out of hand.
You're 89!
We're still here?
Oh, thank God.
I'm just happy somebody else got taxed.
I can't.
I'm so happy.
I'm not alone.
Someone else is actually paying the government's taxes.
Where am I at?
I'm literally paying for Fillion's retirement right now with my taxes.
Thank you.
I'm paying for her care home service.
You should pay for her euthanasia.
Thank God.
I'm out of here.
Goodbye.
Does anyone want to race Crocodile with me?
I fucking...
Oh my God.
No way!
I prefer the road.
No way, bro!
Oh my God.
Race that and another thing!
We gotta extend Fillion's life.
Bro, what is happening?
I feel like the game is just going way too far for me.
I love the government.
I love free healthcare.
Guess one.
Not bad.
Wait, how come someone says choose three and someone doesn't let you choose one?
Yeah.
Three is before you make it to the end.
So when you retire, you can only choose one envelope.
Oh, I see.
I love paying for other people's free healthcare, guys.
Thank you.
Can I get a wheelchair?
I don't need to help you, Fillion.
You never helped us in your lifetime.
Why do I help this boomy?
Oh, thank God.
Somebody finally landed on my face.
Don't tax.
Oh, thank God.
No.
Oh, she left the game.
Very cool.
Oh my God.
Guys, watch this.
My favorite color is black.
Here it is.
Here it comes.
I'm a two millionaire.
Holy frick.
She has not paid a single tax, by the way.
I hope you get audited.
Three lifetimes on a single tax.
You dare attack my entire society?
Yes.
I literally paid for your healthcare.
Come in here and fight me then.
Alright.
All we have to do is push you over, old lady.
I got in, I get the 10k.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh my God, it would be a shame.
There was an...
It would be a shame if there was a window over there in the retirement home.
There would be a shame.
My pension.
Let's go.
And just like that.
Am I the last one left?
Just you, Doobie.
Just Doobie.
Wait, I think you made it.
You make it.
Yeah.
You get to spin, right?
Once?
Again?
Yeah, you get to roll.
Yeah, we all get to roll.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, that's a 100k profit.
Finally!
I made it to the Millionaire's Club.
Yeah!
You got the Millionaire's Club.
I literally have no idea who's going to win this.
Fucking, oh yeah, the two millionaire doesn't know who's going to win.
Well, no, I don't.
She literally has 120.
You're literally two million!
No, she's got the hearts and the piggy banks.
They don't matter!
Money matters a lot!
They matter a lot!
Oh boy, I wonder who's going to win.
Wow.
Who hit two million this game?
Like, legitimately, Doobie's going to win from all the extra junk she's got.
Ooh, a mean feeling went off.
I didn't even get anything.
You did get the, you got the two bonuses for like, yeah.
Damn!
Look, she's going to win!
Doobie's going to win!
I don't think she's going to hit two million from this.
It's impossible.
Oh, Doki won!
Wait, what?
Wait.
No way!
You guys both got first.
You guys both win.
Oh my god, there's no way.
To be fair, if I didn't have to pay all those taxes, I actually could have won.
To be fair, Doobie, if I hadn't taken your 100k at the start, I would have lost.
I literally lost 50% of my income there.
Holy frick.
What happens now?
Look at these losers.
Doki, do you want to settle this?
Fine.
There can only be one.
Here's what I'm going to do.
Okay, Bao or Doobie, who wants to be the one that picks either the number one or two?
Yeah, I'm going to play rock, paper, scissors.
Frick that.
How do we play rock, paper, scissors?
I'm 2D.
We'll have Bao say rock, paper, scissors, shoot, and then we'll say either scissors or rock or paper.
Oh my god, Doobie, what happened to you, Doobie?
You're pixelated.
How about you guys ask Doobie to think of a number between one to a hundred.
The one that's closest wins.
But then she can lie.
No, she won't.
I already picked a number.
Fifty.
Yeah.
Wow, you're so cool.
Fine then.
Get these nuts in your mouth.
Let me take a over or under chat.
Doobie, is she a 69 kind of girl or is she a number one kind of girl?
Let's find out.
I'm going to say 51.
Okay, the number was 94.
No!
Number one?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you could have lied, Doobie.
She already has everything.
Sorry.
You guys both won.
Come on.
We're all winners here.
You're right.
We're all winners.
Nobody lied.
It's a game.
We all learned that going to college was important.
So, congratulations.
Yay!
The chat was like, of course, the tax evader won.
It was only three lifetimes of tax evading.
It wasn't that crazy.
Oh, yeah.
I paid for your healthcare, fillion.
It was only three lifetimes.
Like, it could definitely have been worse for sure.
So, I mean, that's just my personal opinion on it.
Horrible.
GGs, everybody.
Have a fun time.
That was a really fun game.
Yeah.
Yeah, I've never played that game before.
It's alright.
The only issue is that even with different maps, the cards...
I wish the cards were different for different maps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, at least the jobs were different.
Yeah, yeah.
But that was fun.
GGs, everybody.
GGs.
Yeah, it was great collabing with all of you.
Yeah, it was really fun.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Go follow everybody, Chad.
Yeah.
Follow Doobie, Bow, and Fillion.
Yay.
Yeah, I'm gonna talk to my chat a little bit, but thank you for playing.
Thank you.
Let's get out of here, y'all.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, guys.
It was lovely to meet you, Doobie.
Bye, Doobie Bow.
Yeah.
Bye, guys.
Bye-bye.
Bye -bye.
Wow, that was fun, everyone.
That was fun.
I had a great time with Doobie, Bow, and Fillion.
And I had a great time.
I can't believe how fucking unlucky I am with the government.
I love the government.
I love the government so much.
But it was incredibly fun playing with all of them.
And I feel like I think I got taxed at least three times a turn, so yippee.
That's when you know I actually pay my taxes.
But thank you, everyone, for coming.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I am going to rest now because I'm still sick.
So if you guys didn't know, I have a Gamer Subs!
Gamer Subs!
My Gamer Subs thing dropped, so make sure to use my code DokiBird.
It's on the...
I pinned it in my chat.
Support the Gamer Subs thing.
Yippee.
I have like a million things to show.
I have a Hyatt PC case.
I have my concert.
Bye, you guys.
If you guys didn't know, Doobie's going to be in my concert.
With Mint for 3D.
So check it out, too.
Check out the concert in December 14th.
So yeah.
There's that.
Doobie's going to be there.
And...
What else?
The initial.
Oh, yeah.
Vote for me in the streamer awards.
And I think that's it.
Is that really...
I'm so good at shitting.
And tomorrow, I'm going to be announcing the teams for my Apex custom.
Yay!
I'm going to be announcing the events and the rules for my Apex custom I'm organizing.
And be sure to check that one out as well.
For tomorrow at 6pm PST.
That custom has been the most hellish thing I've ever organized.
I've had so many setbacks regarding it.
It's just very unlucky.
And even now, I have last minute shit that came up.
So I'm scrambling right now.
There's so many logistic things that came up.
And I have to negotiate stuff regarding things, regarding the custom.
And it's the most hellish thing I've ever organized.
I've never hit as many roadblocks for this Apex custom.
I've never had so many roadblocks for an event I've organized until now.
This is the most roadblocks I've ever hit.
And so I'm like, oh my god.
It's actually been so stressful.
But I hope everything comes together by next week.
But anyway, by tomorrow!
Because I'm announcing it tomorrow.
Anyway, I'm going to head off now.
Fucking words are hard.
As always, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.